GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE IT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OF AGRICULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- TODAY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMING IN AND OUT
BECAUSE THERE ARE THREE OTHER
COMMITTEES UP BUT WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO HOLD THIS
HEARING TODAY AND AND I KNOW
THAT --
THERE AS EXCITED AS I AM IN A
BIG THANK YOU --
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
FOR BEING HERE.
AS WELL.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LEADING
AGRICULTURAL STATE IN THE NATION.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCED OVER FOUR
HUNDRED COMMERCIAL CROPS WITH
THE VALUE OF FORTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE NEED THE
U. S. AND AG CROPS OF MORE THAN
SEVENTY FIVE DAY THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE U. S. IN AG CROPS.
AND IT AND WE ARE THE SOLE
PRODUCER OF FOURTEEN CROPS
INCLUDING ALMONDS RAISINS OLIVES
DATES FIGS GARLIC HUEY
THROUGHPUT PISTACHIO REASONS ONE
IT'S TO GO I COULD GO ON AND ON
IF YOU LIKE ANY OF THOSE AND YOU
GOT TO BE HAPPY THAT CALIFORNIA
GROSS THEM.
THERE ARE MANY AND I THINK I
LIKE THEM ALL THE I DON'T SEE
ONE THAT I THAT I DON'T
APPRECIATE.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR THE
SUCCESS OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING HIGH
PRODUCTION LAND THE
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE.
EXTENSIVE WATER TRANSFER AN
IRRIGATION SYSTEM USE OF
TECHNOLOGY A GREAT UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM WITH GOOD AGRICULTURAL
RESEARCH AND OUTREACH.
A DIVERSITY OF FARMING
TECHNIQUES AND A POSITIVE BRAND
FOR CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
GOODS.
THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGES FACING
OUR AGRICULTURAL SECTOR TODAY
RANGING FROM REGULATIONS.
ECONOMIC FACTS WITHIN AND
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE WATER
SUPPLY AND USE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS LABOR AND MANY OTHER
ISSUES.
CALIFORNIA HAS SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FARMS AND
RANCHES WHICH IN TOTAL EQUALS
TWENTY FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
ACRES THAT'S REALLY THE REASON
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY. 90% OF
THESE ARE FAMILY FARMS WITH AN
AVERAGE SIZE OF THREE HUNDRED
NINETY THIRTY THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE ACRES --
ALL OF WHICH HAVE THIS
INCREDIBLE CONNECTION TO THE
LAND AND EMBRACE GOOD
STEWARDSHIP.
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO DISCUSS
THE WAY IN WHICH CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE BENEFITS THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND TO UNDERSTAND IN X. EXPLORE
WAYS THAT AGRICULTURE CAN BE AN
ACTIVE PARTNER IN CALIFORNIA IN
REACHING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
GOALS.
OUR PANEL WILL BE DISCUSSING AG
LAND CONSERVATION AND SOIL
HEALTH.
CROP SPECIFIC PROGRAMS AND
CURRENT RESEARCH WORKING TO
EXPAND ON CURRENT AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES.
SO -- I'D
LIKE -- TO
AGAIN THANK --
AGUIAR-CURRY AND SEE IF HE'S GOT
A FEW WHERE SHE WANTS TO SAY ON
THE SUBJECT AND THEN WE'LL GET
STARTED.
WELL AS EVERYBODY THINKS THAT --
AGRICULTURE LISTS ARE NOT REALLY
IN TUNE WITH THE ENVIRONMENT.
JUST LOVING TO SAY.
YES WE DO WE DO CARE AYE FARM
EIGHTY ACRES OF MY BROTHERS AND
SO WE TRY TO DO IT EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
TAKE CARE OF OUR LAND TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE WATER IN
SUSTAINABILITY SO I'M ANXIOUS TO
HEAR SOME NEW IDEAS THANKS FOR
COMING TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO
INVITE OUR FIRST PANEL TO COME
UP AND SPEAK.
SERENA UNGER SENIOR POLICY AND
PLANNING MANAGER FOR AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST.
AND BRIAN SHOW BE ASSOCIATE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY --
AGAIN MY NAME IS SERENA ANGER
AND I'M WITH AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST -- I
HAVE A BACKGROUND IN LAND USE
PLANNING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SO I BRING THAT
PERSPECTIVE TO MY WORK --
ON FARMLAND CONSERVATION --
CAN FIGURE THIS THING OUT
[inaudible]
A OKAY.
THAT HAS TO BE IN POWER POINT
MODE AT VICTOR.
WELL JUST START LIKE I WANTED TO
JUST START --
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT IS
LEAD ME NEED A YOUNGER PERSON TO
OPERATE THIS.
THANK YOU YOU --
WANTED TO START AT THE CONTEXT
OF THE NATIONAL LEVEL AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST --
NATIONAL TEAM JUST RELEASED A
STUDY THIS SPRING CALLED STATE
OF AMERICA'S FARMLAND FARMS
UNDER THREAT --
THIS IS WHAT THE PATTERNS OF
DEVELOPMENT LOOK LIKE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY OVER TWENTY YEARS OF THE
DARKER.
MAROON COLORS ARE BACK HIGH
LEVELS OF CONVERSION FROM --
FARMLAND TO OTHER USES.
I THE STUDY SHOWED THAT OVERALL
DEVELOPMENT DISPROPORTIONATELY
OCCURRED ON AGRICULTURAL LANDS
MORE THAN 70% OF URBAN
DEVELOPMENT AND 62% OF ALL
DEVELOPMENT TOOK PLACE ON
AGRICULTURAL LANDS.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED NEARLY TWICE
AS MUCH LAND AS WE PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DEVELOPING UP LAND WITH GREATER
PRODUCTIVITY.
VERSATILE VERSATA --
VERSATILITY AND RESILIENCE SIX
WERE LOSING THE BEST STUFF --
IF WE ACT HEAD OF ZOOM INTO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY LINE
YOU GUYS PROBABLY ALL KNOW THESE
NUMBERS BUT THIS IS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
REMOVED REMOVING LAND FROM
FARMING USES AT A RATE OF FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES ANNUALLY --
OF THAT LAND CONVERTED 49% WAS
FARMLAND PRIME FARMLAND IN THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. FOR EVERY
FIVE ACRES LEAVING OUT.
THAT THE AVERAGE DENSITY OF THE
STATE'S URBAN AREAS IS LESS THAN
TEN PEOPLE FOR EVERY ACRE
DEVELOPED THAT IS THE VERY
DEFINITION OF LOW DENSITY
DEVELOPMENT SO WE'RE NOT USING
OUR SPACE EFFICIENTLY.
IN CALIFORNIA OR IN THE COUNTRY
F. THE CURRENT TRENDS CONTINUE
ON THIS PATH WERE LIKELY TO LOSE
ANOTHER ONE POINT FIVE TO TWO
MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND.
AGRICULTURAL LAND BY.
TWENTY FIFTY I BET I JUST WANT
TO ZOOM IN AGAIN SETTING THE
CONTEXT FOR THE LATER PART OF
THIS PRESENTATION --
ZOOM INTO THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
OUR CALIFORNIA TEAM JUST
RELEASED A REPORT LAST SPRING
THAT LOOKS AT THE INTERSECTION
OF AGRICULTURAL LAND AND WATER
RESOURCES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
OUR GOALS WERE TO IDENTIFY THE
MOST -- WE
KNOW THAT WHILE EVERY ACRE OF
LAND TO PROTECT PRODUCTION
POSSESSES THE ATTRIBUTES
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT AGRICULTURE.
SOME LAND IS OF HIGHER QUALITY
AND SOME LAND HAS MORE RELIABLE
WATER SOURCES.
KNOWING THE COMBINATION OF THOSE
ATTRIBUTES WE CAN DO BETTER
PLANNING FOR PROTECTING FARMLAND
IN THE VALLEY.
SOME KEY TAKEAWAYS FROM THE
REPORT.
LESS THAN ONE OUT OF TEN ACRES
OF AGRICULTURAL LAND IN THE
VALLEY IS OF HIGH QUALITY AND
LOW WATER STRESS.
BUT THE BIG FINDING.
IN CONTRAST FOUR IN TEN ACRES
ARE OF LOW QUALITY OR
EXPERIENCING HIGH WATER STRESS.
ONE OUT OF SIX ACRES OF WHAT IS
ARGUABLY THE BEST MOST RESILIENT
LAND IN THE VALLEY IS AT RISK OF
BEING DEVELOPED.
BEGIN IN TERMS OF THE WATER
QUALITY IS THE SECOND NUMBER
THAT YOU GAVE.
SO -- FOUR
IN TEN ACRES.
ARE OF LOW QUALITY OR
EXPERIENCING HIGH WATER STRESS.
AND I CAN SHARE THAT REPORT WITH
YOU GUYS --
SO WHAT IF WE'RE ABLE TO AVOID
CONVERSION OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
LANDS WHETHER THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS THAT THESE LANDS HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE.
WE KNOW IT'S ABOUT SAVING OUR
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY WE KNOW
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING THE
NATION'S FOOD SECURITY WE NEED
FOOD -- OR
BECOMING INCREASINGLY AWARE OF
THE POTENTIAL FOR AGRICULTURAL
LANDS TO SEQUESTER CARBON FROM
THE ATMOSPHERE WHEN THEY'RE
MANAGED PROPERLY.
WERE ALSO INCREASINGLY BECOMING
AWARE OF THE GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE POTENTIAL THAT
AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE INNER CITIES.
PROVIDES TO HELP WITH THE
STATE'S WATER.
WE ALSO NOW HAVE A LOT OF DATA
THAT SUPPORTS AGRICULTURAL
PRESERVATION AS A GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES I WILL BE
FOCUSING ON THAT YELLOW BUBBLE --
BUT IF WE CAN'T STABILIZE
HURTLING TO PROTECT IT FROM
BEING LOST WE CAN ACHIEVE ANY OF
THESE THINGS.
THIS QUOTE IN ALL RITA IS FROM
AUTHORS OF ONE OF THE MOST
COMPLETE REVIEWS OF LITERATURE
ON REDUCING AGRICULTURAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THEY
LOOKED AT ABOUT TWENTY STUDIES
OF EVERYTHING FROM NUTRIENT
MANAGEMENT. TO COVER CROPPING
ANDCOMPOSTING AND HERE WAS
THEIR ULTIMATE CONCLUSION.
BECAUSE THE AVERAGE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS FROM URBAN LAND
USES ARE ORDERS OF MAGNITUDE
HIGHER THAN THOSE FROM
CALIFORNIA CROPLANDS.
FARMLAND PRESERVATION MORE THAN
ANY OTHER MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
WILL LIKELY HAVE THE SINGLE
GREATEST IMPACT IN STABILIZING
AND REDUCING FUTURE EMISSIONS
ACROSS MULTIPLE LAND USE
CATEGORY.
SEE THE REASON THAT'S IMPORTANT.
IS THAT THAT [inaudible]
THAT.
HAS NO PLACE WEEK THERE'S NO
WHERE WE WERE DOING THIS.
AND IN IT AS A GHG REDUCTION
STRATEGY.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
TAKEAWAY THAT YOU CAN TAKE FROM
THIS COMMITTEE YEAH IT'S IT
REALLY WHEN WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT OTHER
THINGS.
WE HAVE AND THEY'RE UP THERE ARE
HINTS OF THIS IN THE SCOPING
PLAN THE CALIFORNIA BUT THEIR
HITS.
SO WE NEED TO START IMPLEMENTING
THAT HITS --
INCE'S THE OPERATIVE WORD THERE
HAVE RIGHT --
SO AND HERE'S WHAT THE MAGNITUDE
LOOKS LIKE --
A COUPLE OF OTHER STUDIES SHOW
WITH THAT MAGNITUDE IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
CROP PRODUCTION AND URBAN THAT
LAND USES AND THEIR RELATIVES
GHG EMISSIONS SO YOU YOU MAY
KNOW OF THE WORK DONE BY
PROFESSOR LOUISE JACKSON AND HER
COLLEAGUES AT UC DAVIS.
THEY WERE THE FIRST TO ESTABLISH
THE CONNECTION BETWEEN
URBANIZATION OF FARMLAND AND THE
INCREASE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THEIR WORK FOUND THAT IN YOLO
COUNTY GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS --
FROM URBAN USES ROUGHLY SEVENTY
TIMES GREATER ON A PER ACRE
BASIS THAN THOSE FROM
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS.
BUT WE TOOK THAT AND WE DID A
SECOND STUDY WE WANTED TO LOOK
AT CROPS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CROPS AND
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CITIES --
SO WE REACHED SIMILAR
CONCLUSIONS LOOKING AT THE
STATE'S LEADING CROPS WHICH ARE
HERE IN THIS GRAPH --
IN THIRTEEN CITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS STUDY FOUND THAT
THIS FINDING HOLDS TRUE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S TOP.
HER TUMULT MULTIPLY URBAN I
TYPES.
I'M ON AVERAGE OUR CALCULATIONS
SHOW THAT THE ANNUAL PER ACRE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
THE PRODUCTION OF CALIFORNIANS
LEADING CROPS.
AVERAGE FIFTY TONS PER ACRE
LOWER FIFTY TONS OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS EQUIVALENT I'M
LOWER THAN THE EMISSIONS FROM
URBAN AREAS AROUND THE STATE.
THIS TRANSLATES INTO A FIFTY
EIGHT TIMES HIGHER GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS FROM URBAN AREAS
THEN FROM IRRIGATED CROPLAND.
AGAINST IT'S THE SAME MAGNITUDE
SO WE'RE SAYING FIFTY EIGHT TO
SEVENTY TIMES GREATER BASED ON
THOSE TWO STUDIES --
NOW WHERE I LIKE TO HONE IN IS
ON LOCATION LOCATION LOCATION
DENSITY AND CITY DENSITY --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THAT RESEARCH --
AT IN ALL OF IT THAT SHOWS THAT
THE CONVERSION OF CROPLAND TECH
URBAN USES IT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY.
MEAN THAT THE CONVERSION TO
URBAN USES INCREASES GREENHOUSE
GAS AMOUNTS BY THOSE AMOUNTS --
THE MAGNITUDE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
URBAN DEVELOPMENT AND AYE GLAND
IS A STATIC NUMBER BASED ON THE
EMISSIONS.
OF URBAN AREAS IN CROP AREAS AT
A GIVEN POINT IN TIME OF THE
STUDIES WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO
AND WE WILL ADD.
POPULATION AND ECONOMIC
ACTIVITIES THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT WHERE THOSE THINGS GO --
BECAUSE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FROM URBAN LAND USES ARE KNOWN
TO VARY WITH THE DENSITY OF
DEVELOPMENT.
FUTURE CONCENTRATION OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY WILL INFLUENCE WHAT
PERCENT OF EMISSIONS WILL
ACTUALLY BE AVOIDED SO IT'S ALL
ABOUT WHERE AND HOW DENSE.
LOW DENSITY DEVELOPMENT PRODUCES
MORE GREENHOUSE GASES PER CAPITA
THAN HIGH EFFICIENT.
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT.
SO LET'S THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE
FOR A MINUTE AF T. SHOWS THAT
WITH FUTURE COMPACT DEVELOPMENT --
THERE WOULD BE A 55% NET SAVINGS
BETWEEN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AGRICULTURAL AND URBAN EMISSIONS
AS A RESULT OF CONCENTRATING.
OUR POPULATION ON FEWER ACRES OF
LAND.
IF WE WANT TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
LOS STILL ALLOWING THE STATE TO
EXPAND ITS ECONOMY AND AT THE
SAME TIME SAVE OUR FARMLAND FROM
BEING CONVERTED TO DEVELOPMENT
WE MUST DEVELOP AT HIGHER
DENSITIES --
AND IF THE STATE AND ESPECIALLY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES COMMIT TO
BETTER PATTERNS OF DEVELOPMENT.
I'M OUR RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT --
WILL BE PUT OUT A GOAL AT IF.
THE ANNUAL LOSS OF FARMLAND TO
DEVELOPMENT IN CALIFORNIA
RESERVE REDUCED BY 50% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND 75% BY TWENTY
FIFTY THAT WOULD BE THE
EQUIVALENT OF TAKING TWO MILLION
CARS OFF THE ROAD EVERY YEAR.
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
VICE SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SEVEN BILLION MILES EVERY YEAR.
AND SAVING ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND.
THESE ARE ESTIMATES BASED ON OUR
RESEARCH SHOWING THE MAGNITUDE
DIFFERENCE OF GHG EMISSIONS
BETWEEN URBAN AND AGRICULTURAL
LANDS.
IF WE FOLLOW THE STATE'S
TRAJECTORY.
TO TWENTY THIRTY UP WE COULD
MEET.
GEE IT TO MEET ITS YET SHE
REDUCTION GOALS THIS AMOUNT
WOULD.
EQUAL 18% OF THE STATE'S OVERALL
GHG REDUCTION GOALS THAT'S
THAT'S NOT NOTHING.
AND SO IN REGARDS TO THAT IF IF
I CAN ASK A REAL QUICK QUESTION
WHAT ASSUMPTIONS DID YOU MAKE IN
REGARDS TO THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE IN THAT.
URBAN AREA IT BECAUSE PART OF
THE CHALLENGE [inaudible]
IS THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ACT
CONVERSION?
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT LOS
ANGELES OAKLAND OR SAN FRANCISCO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND WHEN YOU ASK THEM IF THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN INCREASING
DENSITIES --
REDUCING.
PARKING SPACES AND INCREASING
THE INTENSITY OF DEVELOPMENT.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR
THAT BECAUSE THERE ISN'T THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE.
THERE IS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
MOBILITY INFRASTRUCTURE SO I'M
I'M WONDERING IF YOU MADE ANY
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THAT I DON'T
DESERVE IT THE WAY THAT WE GOT
TO THAT 55% --
WITH USING THEIR SAID SOFTWARE
THAT HEALTH WORK ANALYTICS
PRODUCE BECAUSE URBAN FOOTPRINT
YOU MIGHT HAVE HEARD OF THAT.
AND SO THEY DO --
KIND OF REGIONAL URBAN PLANNING
SCENARIO DEVELOPMENT USING G.
EACH G. IN A LOT OF OTHER --
AT METRICS.
I DON'T NO WHAT'S EMBEDDED IN
THERE BUT THAT'S OUR
AUTHORISATIONS BEATS AMERICA.
AND THAT'S A VERY GOOD POINT.
I'M STILL OUR CALL TO ACTION IS
TO SET STATEWIDE GOALS FOR
FARMING CONSERVATION THAT.
THIRTY AT 50% BY 303075% BY
TWENTY FIFTY OUT OF THE WAY I
SEE IT IS THE SAME WAY THAT WE
HAVE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THE ARENA.
WHERE THE STATE MANDATES A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS
IN EVERY REGION MUST BE PLANNED
FOR HIM BELT WE SHOULD DO THE
SAME FOR FARMING CONSERVATION --
WE SHOULD REFORM PLANNING LAWS
SO THAT COMMUNITIES CAN BETTER --
REDUCE THEIR PER CAPITAL AND
CONSUMPTION FOR DEVELOPMENT --
WHICH DEFINITELY INCLUDES MORE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS I'M.
WE SHOULD I ADOPT STATEWIDE --
MITIGATION POLICIES SO THAT WE
CAN BALANCE --
BUT IS LOST IN FARMLAND --
WE SHOULD PRIORITIZE THE
CONSERVATION OF THE HIGH QUALITY
LAND GETTING BACK TO OUR SAN
JOAQUIN STUDY.
AND WE SHOULD INCREASE FUNDING
TO HELP SUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES THAT --
PRODUCED ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON AT CHAIR
MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS BRIAN SHOW BY THE
ASSOCIATE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
CAL CANNED THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK --
AND I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF
AGRICULTURE IT'S SOMETHING OUR
COALITION.
I BELIEVE DEEPLY IN.
I LIKE YOU AND PROBABLY EVERYONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM --
OUR COALITION OF FARMERS
RANCHERS RESEARCHERS AND
TECHNICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
A BELIEVES THAT WITH THE RIGHT
POLICIES INCENTIVES AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN PLACE.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCERS CAN I DO
ALL OF THE ABOVE SUSTAIN GLOBAL
FOOD SECURITY PROTECT OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES.
PROVIDE FOR ECONOMICALLY VIBRANT
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND MAINTAIN
OUR OUR WORLD CLASS I GLANCE IF
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT.
I MEAN AND THE INNOVATIVE
PRODUCERS --
IN OUR NETWORK OF PROVEN ALL OF
THIS IS POSSIBLE.
I'M SAID HIM AND TO TELL YOU
ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA IS SCALING
UP THEIR INNOVATION.
I AM BUT BEFORE I DO I FEEL I
HAVE TO ADDRESS WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS THE GREATEST THREAT TO
AGRICULTURE AND THE ENVIRONMENT
IN THE LONG TERM.
SO AS YOU ALL WELL KNOW BECAUSE
YOU'RE DEALING WITH IT RIGHT NOW --
IN JUST THE PAST EIGHT YEARS
WE'VE EXPERIENCED THE WORST
DROUGHT SOME ST A MILLENNIUM.
THE SECOND WETTEST WINTER ON
RECORD AND OF COURSE A NUMBER OF
THE STATE'S LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES.
AND WE KEEP OUR BREAKING THE
RECORDS THAT NO ONE WANTS TO
BREAK [inaudible]
RIGHT -- AND
OF COURSE MANY FACTORS CAN
EXPLAIN ANY SINGLE EVENTS OR
NATURAL DISASTER BUT IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS
DIALING UP THE FREQUENCY AND AND
THE INTENSITY OF ALL OF THESE.
SO THESE HAVE --
FAIRLY PROFOUND DE CONSEQUENCES
FOR AGRICULTURE AS AN INDUSTRY
DEPENDENT ON THE WEATHER --
REFLECTING THIS THIS NEW REALITY --
A YOU SEE PAPER PUBLISHED THIS
SPRING BY SIX A UC RESEARCHERS
[inaudible]
PROJECTED THAT --
IF CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUES
UNABATED BY TWENTY FIFTY YIELDS
ARE PROJECTED TO DECLINE BY 40%
FOR AVOCADOS.
AND 20% FOR ALMONDS TABLE GRAPES
ORANGES AND WALNUTS WHICH AS YOU
NOTED TEAR AND SOME OF THE
BIGGEST CROPS IN THE STATE.
BY THE END OF THE CENTURY THAT
THE PICTURE IS EVEN BLEAKER THE
RESEARCHERS PROJECT A 50%
INCREASE IN SEVERE DROUGHTS AND
SEVERE FLOODS.
AND A POTENTIAL SIXTY FIVE LOS
AT PERCENT LOSS IN OUR SNOWPACK --
ALSO THERE BUT THAT'S ONLY A
PARTIAL LIST --
SO THIS IS THAT THE SLOW MOVING
CRISIS FACING OUR INDUSTRY AND
AND PARTICULARLY FACING --
MY GENERATION OF FARMERS WHO
HAFTED FOR PREPARE FOR THIS
FEATURE.
BUT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU A GOOD
STORY -- SO
WE BELIEVE THAT --
THIS IS A CRISIS WE HAVE ALL OF
THE TOOLS TO SOLVE.
AND AGRICULTURE IN PARTICULAR.
ARE HAS A UNIQUE ROLE TO PLAY
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
WHAT WE CALL ABUNDANT SOLUTIONS
I'VE ASKED TO LOOK AT OF
PRACTICES?
THAT WE'VE COLLECTIVELY DEEMED
CLIMATE SMART AGRICULTURE.
THAT BOTH ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND ALSO IMPROVE THE RESILIENCE
OF OUR FARMS AND RANCHES AND TO
ITS IMMEDIATE IMPACTS THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING NOW.
AND MOST OF THESE PRACTICES ALSO
HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL COULD
BENEFITS WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT.
SO CALIFORNIA'S ACCELERATING
THIS TRANSITION THE CLIMATE
SMART I CAN FOUR WAYS.
BUILDING HEALTHY SOILS SAVING
WATER AND ENERGY.
PRODUCING LIVESTOCK METHANE
EMISSIONS AND CONSERVING AT RISK
FARMLAND.
I DON'T KNOW OTHERS ARE GOING TO
ARE GOING TO COVER MOST OF THESE
TOPICS AND IN MORE DETAIL.
I'M SO I'M GONNA FOCUS MOSTLY ON
HEALTHY SOILS ABOUT IT WILL
TOUCH JUST BRIEFLY ON THE OTHERS
[inaudible]
SO.
WIRE WE BUILDING HEALTHY SOILS
AND WHAT IS THAT WHAT IS THAT
EVEN MEAN [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
BY ADDING.
A SMALL LAYER OF COMPOST AND
MULCH PLANTING COVER CROPS.
AND REDUCING TILLAGE YOU'RE
INSTALLING VEGETATIVE BUFFERS ON
THE EDGES OF FIELDS.
ANYONE OF TWENTY PLUS PRACTICE
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NAG AS
HAS RECOGNIZED AS A HEALTHY
CELLS PRACTICE.
AND WE CAN IMPROVE THE THE
FUNCTION --
AND THE HEALTH OF THE BIOLOGY IN
THE STRUCTURE IN THE SOIL.
AND IN TURN.
THAT TURNS ARE --
OUR SOIL'S INTO SPONGES.
THE USDA ESTIMATES THAT FOR
EVERYONE PERCENT INCREASE AND
SOIL ORGANIC MATTER.
SO CAN ABSORB AND RETAIN AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
GALLONS OF WATER PER ACRE.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT HAS.
AT POSITIVELY.
IMPACTS ON DROUGHT RESILIENCE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
AB REDUCED FLOOD RISK AND AND
REDUCE SOIL EROSION.
HEALTHY CELLS ALSO INCREASE A
NUTRIENT AVAILABILITY TO THE
PLANTS IN THERE FOR INCREASED
THEIR HEALTH AND YIELDS.
AND THEY DO ALL OF THIS THROUGH --
PRETTY MAGICAL PROCESS CALLED
PHOTOSYNTHESIS WHERE THEY TAKE
CARMEN OUT OF THE ATMOSPHERE AND
PUT IT IN THE FORM OF PLANT
MATTER AND MICROBIAL AND THAT
LIVING ORGANISMS.
BENEATH HER FEET WHERE IT'S
USEFUL AND PRODUCTIVE.
I HAVE THIS PICTURE HERE IS OF
SANDY MCGINNIS GARCIA SHE'S A
FARMER IN WATSONVILLE AND ONE OF
THE HUNDRED AND TWELVE FARMERS
HAVE RECEIVED HEALTHY SOILS
GRANTS.
AND SHE SAYS THAT.
WE CAN REDUCE OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS AND FERTILIZER
APPLICATIONS AND SAVE WATER AT
THE TIME IT'S A WIN WIN WIN FOR
FARMERS --
THEY'RE GONNA BE A NUMBER OF
OTHER PICTURES OF A FARMER'S ON
MY IT NEXT SLIDES I'M I DON'T
HAVE TIME. TO TO QUOTE ALL OF
THEM ASSURE ALL OF THEIR STORIES
BUT I WANT TO KNOW THAT
AND WE HAVE THE STORIES OF SANDY
AND THIRTY OTHER --
FARMERS WHO RECEIVED CLIENTS
MIGHT AYE GRANTS ON OUR WEBSITES
AND SCRUBBING THEIR PROJECTS
THEIR MOTIVATIONS AND AND THEIR
QUOTES.
AND CENTER TRUCKS TO CHECK THAT
OUT.
SO WHAT IS THE STATUS OF HEALTHY
CELLS PRACTICE ADOPTION IN THE
STATE -- WE
RECENTLY COMPILED DATA --
ON THIS QUESTION TO HELP INFORM
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD* OWN
WORKINGMAN'S IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
THIS IS THE PLAN WHICH WILL SET
A TARGET --
FOR WHAT AGRICULTURE CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE'S
OVERALL CLIMATE STRATEGY BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND SO ALL THIS
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF A THE STATS
THAT WE WE FOUND --
APPROXIMATELY 6% OF ALMOND
ACREAGE IN THE STATE IS ALREADY
USING COVER CROPS.
ABOUT 10% OF THE FARMS IN THE
STATE USE CONSERVATION TILLAGE.
OUR A WHOPPING 95% OF VINEYARDS --
ALREADY IS COVER CROPS REPLY
COMPOST.
AT JUST OVER THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND CROPLAND ACRES
ARE CERTIFIED ORGANIC WHICH
MEANS AND THEY'RE USING MULTIPLE
HEALTHY CELLS PRACTICES.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE ORGANIC
RANGE LAND.
AND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES --
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WERE UNDER
NRCS EQUAL CONTRACT TO IMPLEMENT
SO HEALTH PRACTICES.
SO WHEN WE HAD ALL OF THAT UP WE
COME UP WITH A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE --
THAT APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES ARE CURRENTLY
USING HEALTHY SO AS PRACTICES.
SO WHAT IS THE STATE DOING TO
WRAP THAT UP.
I WELL IT'S PRIMARILY INVESTING
AT YOU ALL I HAVE INVESTED IN.
A THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE'S HEALTHY CELLS
PROGRAM.
OUR THIS PROGRAM DIRECTLY
INCENTIVIZE FARMERS TO A TRYOUT
AND ADOPT THESE NEW PRACTICES.
IT GIVES AN A THREE YEAR WINDOW
TO TO FIGURE IT OUT MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL --
AND SO FAR THERE'S A THAT MONEY
IS GONE TWO HUNDRED TWELVE
PROJECTS AND THIRTY FIVE
COUNTIES.
AND I DON'T ESPECIALLY NO --
TWENTY EIGHT OF THOSE ARE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS.
WHICH ARE UNIQUE HAVE BECAUSE
THEY THEY CREATE OPPORTUNITY FOR
FARMERS TO LEARN THE WAY.
FARMERS RANCHERS LEARN BEST AND
THEY REQUIRE THAT HUNDRED TWENTY
FARMERS OVER THREE YEARS VISIT
THE SITE.
AND LEARN FROM WHAT THE FARMER
AND HOST IS DOING.
BLOCKING THAT FENCE LINES
KICKING THE DIRT --
TALKING SHOP ABOUT PRACTICES AND
SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT --
COMPONENT AND INNOVATION FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
AND OF COURSE THIS IS ALREADY
HAVING IMPACTS --
YOU CAN SEE THAT YOUR ACTIONS --
THOSE ARE ANNUAL SO THOSE WILL
CONTINUE --
TO TO ACCUMULATE OVER TIME --
SO WE ALSO WANTED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION WHAT KIND OF IMPACT
COULD THIS PROGRAM HAVE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND SO WE LOOKED
AT TWO SCENARIOS A LOW AND HIGH --
AND BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS OF OF
THE FIRST ROUND OF THE PROGRAM.
AYE WE ESTIMATE THAT IF IF THE
STATE INVESTED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN THIS
PROGRAM --
WE'D ACHIEVE AN ADDITIONAL THREE
NINE THIRTY THOUSAND TWO MILLION
ACRES.
UNDER HEALTHY CELLS --
MANAGEMENT BY --
TWENTY THIRTY AND THE RANGE
THEIR REFLECTS OR OR DEPENDS ON
EXTENT WHICH FARMERS APPLY FOR
AND MULTIPLE PRACTICES OR JUST
WANTED TIME.
I AM YOU COULD SEE THAT IN THE
FIFTY MILLION A SCENARIO I WOULD
BE INCREASING THE ACREAGE BY A
SIX AND SIXTY TO TWO MILLION
ACRES -- BUT
ALL NOTE AGAIN THAT WHEN
CONSIDERING THE IMPACTS OF
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS AND THE
GROWING BODY OF RESEARCH --
POINTING TO THE VALUE OF THESE
PROGRAMS OF THESE PRACTICES AND
WE DO THINK THE ADOPTION RATE
WILL ACCELERATE AND AND GROW
MUCH BEYOND THAT.
I AM SEMINAR BREEZE THROUGH A
ACTION ON THESE OF WHAT'S THE
BIGGEST COST TO THESE PROGRAMS
IS IT THE MATERIAL.
VISIT THE APPLICATION IS IT THE
INFORMATION I MEAN WHAT WHAT
WHAT.
WHAT IS THE MONEY GOING TO DO I
GUESS SYSTEM [inaudible]
YEAH -- SO.
MATERIALS AND THE LABOR OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
I WENT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS AND THEIR
THEY GET SOME PORTION FUNDING TO
DO OUTREACH AND EDUCATE --
SANDERS GOING TO BREEZE THROUGH
THESE OTHER THREE BECAUSE OTHER
FOLKS I THINK WE'LL TALK MORE
ABOUT THESE --
OF COURSE CALIFORNIA IS WISELY
ACCELERATING --
INVESTMENTS TO SAY WATER AND
ENERGY ON FARMS.
THE STATE WATER EFFICIENCY
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM OR SWEEP --
HAS INVESTED IN SIX HUNDRED
FOURTEEN PROJECTS ACROSS THIRTY
THREE COUNTIES --
IT'S EXTREMELY EXTREMELY POPULAR --
APPLICATIONS FOR FARMERS
OUTNUMBER AWARDS BY NEARLY THREE
TO ONE RATIO --
AND IT'S ALREADY HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT AND WATER SAVINGS.
FOR THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW HOW TO
IMAGINE SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
ACRE FEET YOUR HEAD IT'S ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT TO THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND OLYMPICS WHEN SWIMMING
POOLS.
THAT'S NOT EASY TO IMAGINE
EITHER BUT I SO WERE ALSO A
REDUCING LIVESTOCK METHANE
EMISSIONS --
I THINK SOMEONE ELSE IS GOING TO
TALK ABOUT I JUST YEARS I'M I'M
JUST GONNA TALK ABOUT THE
ALTERNATE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM BECAUSE AND THE PROJECTS
IT FUNDS ARE THE ONES THAT WORK
FOR AND THE PRIMARILY SMALL AND
MID SKILLED AREAS IN OUR NETWORK --
SO.
IT JUST IN ITS FIRST ROUND LAST
YEAR THIRTY FOUR MILLION WAS
REQUESTED AT TWENTY FOUR MILLION
WAS AWARDED TO SEVENTEEN
PROJECTS --
AND BECAUSE NOTHING IS --
THIRTY TO EIGHTY TIMES MORE
POTENT CARBON DIOXIDE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS --
FROM FROM THE SERVER ARE PRETTY
IMMENSE --
THE OTHER BENEFITS OF THIS
PROGRAM ARE THAT --
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU CONVERT A
MANURE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM FROM A
WET SYSTEM TO DRY SYSTEM?
AND YOU'RE SEPARATING SOLIDS AND
IN MOST CASES THERE COMPOSTING
THEM IN APPLYING THEM BACK TO
THE LAND --
SO THAT'S INCREASING NUTRIENTS
AVAILABILITY FOR FORAGE AND FEED
CROPS -- IT
ALSO PAYS FOR PRACTICES TO GET --
LIVESTOCK AND A COMPOST PACKED
BARNES AND WHICH THERE'S
RESEARCH SHOWING IMPROVES
LIVESTOCK HEALTH --
AND ALSO OUT IN THE PASTURE --
AND BY SWITCHING TO A DRY SYSTEM
ALSO REDUCING WATER USE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT [inaudible]
SO.
AND THEN LASTLY WE JUST HEARD
ALL OF THE REASONS WE SHOULD BE
CONSERVING AT RISK FARMLANDS --
I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THE
SUSTAINABLE AG LANDS
CONSERVATION PROGRAM OR SELL --
HAS CONSERVE FARM AND OTHER
REMARKABLY FAST CLIP COMPARED TO
PREVIOUS CONSERVATION PROGRAMS.
I JUST THREE YEARS IT'S
PERMANENTLY PROTECTED EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRES AND FIFTY TWO
EASEMENTS [inaudible]
AND THIS ALSO PAYS FOR TOUCHING
ON THE LAND USE PLANNING PIECE
THAT'S THAT ESRI MENTIONED --
IT ALSO PAYS FOR A STRATEGY AND
PLANNING GRANTS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO COME UP WITH THEIR
OWN POLICY IDEAS AND ORDINANCES --
THAT WILL.
ADD DRIVE DEVELOPMENT AWAY FROM
OUR PRIME PRIME FARMLAND --
SO. TO WRAP UP --
THE THREAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE
ALL FEEL IT EVEN IF EVEN IF SOME
FARMERS DON'T.
SAY CALLED BY THAT NAME EVERY
FARMER HAS A STORY OF HOW THEY
FACE SOMETHING THAT THEY'VE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE --
INNER IN RECENT HISTORY --
AND SO THAT THE THREAT IS IS
SERIOUS AND IT'S NOW.
AMEND WE'VE A LOT TO LOSE IF WE
DON'T HAVE TO ACT QUICKLY.
AND YET WE ALSO HAVE SO MUCH TO
GAIN IF WE ARE TO FULLY INVEST
AND IMPLEMENT.
THESE KIND OF SMART AGRICULTURAL
SOLUTIONS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR HON EVER ON TALK ABOUT
TODAY -- AND
SO I IN THINKING ABOUT THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION WITH A NEW
GOVERNOR --
AND WHAT LOOKS LIKE INCREASING
CAP AND TRADE REVENUE WE THINK
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO RE PRIORITIZE
THESE MULTI BENEFIT.
AGRICULTURAL SOLUTIONS AND AND
IN THEIR LEGISLATIVE A
EXPENDITURE PLAN --
SO WITH THAT I'LL.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND COSMIC QUESTIONS.
GREAT CONCLUSION THAT'S REALLY
THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
CAN WE BE DOING BETTER.
AND AS WE FOCUS ON THAT.
UTILIZING OUR PRECIOUS FARMLAND
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS LET ME
SEE IF.
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION I AM HER PERCENT
BEHIND THIS I WORKED AGAINST
FUNDING FOR YOU LAST YEAR.
HAVEN'T ALWAYS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
BUT I THINK PEOPLE JUST NOT
AWARE OF THE BENEFITS OF THESE
PROJECTS THESE ARE REALLY ON THE
GROUND AND THEY WORK PROJECTS --
LIKE YOU SAID IN A SWEEP THERE'S
MANY PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROJECT AND
WE CAN'T ACCOMMODATE EVERYONE
AND I WISH WE COULD --
BUT I'M ALT CONTINUE TO BE A
CHAMPION TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE PROJECTS WORKS.
I GOT MANY PHONE CALLS AMERICAN
FARMLAND THESE THAT OF PEOPLE
GIVE ME A CALL AND I THOUGHT
THAT ONE OF THE MOST COMPELLING
ONES OF THAT I HAD AS I OWNING A
RANCH IN THE MY FATHER FARMED
FOR YEARS AND HE DID IT.
HIS WAY.
AND NOW THE FAMILIES ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT HEALTHY SOILS AND
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY PUT A COVER
CROP IN THE WALLET ORCHARD OR
HOW WE GONNA REPLACE ALL PART OF
THE WALL WITH THE ORCHARD HOW DO
WE MAKE THE SOIL.
SO IT'S BETTER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS FOR THE
OF THE PLANT SO ANYWAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PRESENTATION --
RIGHT ON KEEP WORKING HARD ON
THIS BECAUSE WE GET THERE WE GET
EVERYBODY EDUCATED ON HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SO THE ONLY THE ONLY COMMENT I
HAVE IN TERMS OF THE GOALS FOR
THE FARMLAND TRUST IS --
AT THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS --
IN.
THAT OUR CURRENT SYSTEM DOESN'T.
INCENTIVIZE BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO RURAL OR
SUBURBAN AREAS.
AND I THINK IT'S IT'S THE
MISSING PIECE IS THAT
[inaudible]
IS.
IF WAY DON'T DO IT RIGHT THAN
PEOPLE JUST MOVE FURTHER AND
FURTHER OUT.
AND THEN THEN WE DON'T WE LOSE
THE BENEFIT OF THE CREEK
GREENHOUSE GAS CLOSE CLOSE AND
SO -- IT
IT'S GOING TO BECOME
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT THAT ANY
URBANIZATION INCLUDE ANY
CONNECTION.
WE START ADDING THE CONNECTIONS --
FOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION SO
THAT WE CAN ENCOURAGE --
THAT THE DENSER BUILDING.
WITH THE REDUCTION IN PARKING.
AND AND WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
GET OUT OF THEIR VEHICLES SINGLE
OCCUPANCY VEHICLES ARE JUST WHAT
WE NEED TO MAKE THAT SHIFT IN.
HOW WE DO IT IS WITH GOOD
PLANNING I GUESS THAT'S THAT
THAT'S MY BIG POINT AND I KEEP
SAYING?
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GET.
FROM HERE TO SALINAS IN THE
TRAIN BUT IT TAKES ME TWICE AS
LONG AND PART OF IT IS IN A BUS.
AND SO IT BECOMES REALLY
INCONVENIENT AND MOST PEOPLE
WOULD RATHER TAKE THEIR OWN
VEHICLE AND SO --
UNLESS WE START TYING OUR
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOLLARS WITH
OUR YOU KNOW THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PIECES ON I THINK WE'RE GONNA
MISS THAT OPPORTUNITY WILL
CONTINUE TO SPRAWL LIKE THIS IS
MY POINT TOTALLY AGREE.
THANK YOU.
IF THERE ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
I WANT TO THINK THIS PAN PANEL
REALLY SET THE GROUNDWORK --
FOR YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND I REALLY APPRECIATE --
YOU BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE NOW AT LIKE TO ASK
THE SECOND PANEL TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
JOHN CHANDLER FROM CHANDLER
FARMS.
ALL BUT MANAGER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RIGHTS COMMISSION.
MIKE LINES DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THE AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA.
AND MICHAEL BOOK ADORO
REPRESENTING GARY CARES
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible] TO CHANDLER --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE OUT FIRST LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING I THINK THAT IT'S A A
GOOD TOPIC TO TALK ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPACTS ON AGRICULTURE AND
AGRICULTURE'S IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT --
I AM A FAMILY FARMER FROM I JUST
SOUTH OF FRESNO SMALL TOWN
CALLED SELMA.
NOW MY FAMILY'S BEEN FARMING THE
SAME GROUND FOR WELL OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS ON NOW THE FOURTH
GENERATION FARMING THE GROUND
WITH MY FATHER AND MY BROTHER --
AMONG THE CROPS THAT WE FARM ARE
OUR LARGEST IS ALMONDS I WE GROW
CITRUS WE HAVE SOME RAISIN
GRAPES --
SOME PEACHES PLUMS AT AND A
LITTLE BIT OF WINE GRAPES AND
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
HARVESTING OUR PEACHES RAISINS
AND ARE ALMONDS SO IT'S A VERY
BUSY TIME OF YEAR.
WE'LL THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
BECAUSE IT'S IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT YOUR HAIR BUT I I
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH WORK IT IS
STIMPY RIGHT THE MIDDLE OF THE
SEASON.
WELL I IT IS IMPORTANT SUBJECTS
I I FIGURED IS IMPORTANT TAKE
TIME TO COME HERE --
YEAH AS AS WE FARM AND WE'VE
BEEN FARMING THE SAME GROUND FOR
SO LONG THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CHANGES AND HOW AGRICULTURE HAS.
EXISTED IN CALIFORNIA NOT ALONE
LET ALONE THAT TYPES OF CROPS
THAT WE HAVE FARM ABOUT HOW WE
ARE FARMING IT.
AND A BIG PART OF THAT HIS LEAD
TOWARDS SOME VAST IMPROVEMENTS
IN AGRICULTURE'S ROLE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT --
WE WE TALK A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
ABOUT -- THE
EARLIER PANEL TALKED ABOUT WATER
EFFICIENCY ON OUR FARM ALONE --
WE HAVE BIT STARTED --
IMPLEMENTING SOME --
PROCESSES TO INCREASE OUR WATER
EFFICIENCY WHEN I WAS YOUNGER WE
USED TO USE ALL FLOOD IRRIGATION --%
ON OUR FARM AND THAT STARTED TO
CHANGE WE STILL HAVE SOME FLOOD
IRRIGATION BUT WE'RE BEGINNING
TO MOVE AWAY FROM --
FLOOD IRRIGATION MORE PRECISION
WATERING THROUGH MICROSPORUM
COLORS AND DRIPPED.
AND AL LOT OF THE CHANGES
INCREASED MORE RECENTLY BECAUSE
OF STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
STATE AS A NEW AND STRICTER
RULES COME DOWN ON OUR WATER
DURING THE DROUGHT --
A PROGRAMS LIKE YOU HEARD
EARLIER WE PROGRAM WE HAVE BEEN
A SUCCESSFUL --
APPLICANT AND REWARDED --
A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT PROJECTS
THROUGH THE SWEET PROGRAM AND
THEY'VE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT ON OUR FARM --
BOTH ON ENERGY EFFICIENCY BY
INSTALLING A HELPING US TO
INSTALL A SOLAR SYSTEM PLANT TO
A POWER OUR ELECTRIC PUMPS.
AND TO CONVERT OUR SOME OF OUR
FLOOD IRRIGATION FIELDS TO
MICROSPORUM CLAIRE'S AND DRIP
SYSTEMS.
AND WHEN UP FROM THOSE CHANGES
WE HAVE SEEN --
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT.
PART OF THAT PROGRAM ALSO I CAN
SEE A LOT OF OUR NEIGHBORS --
THAT FARM NEAR US HAVE BEEN
APPLYING FOR AND PARTICIPATING
IN THAT PROGRAM AND FIELDS THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN FLOOD
IRRIGATED ARE STARTING TO MOVE
TOWARDS THESE MORE PRECISION
WATERING.
AND THAT ALONE RC AS WHERE
YOU'RE GONNA SEE REAL
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT ON FARM
WATER USE IS A THROUGH THOSE
PROGRAMS AND PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN FARMERS AND THE STATE AS
WE WORK TOGETHER TO FIND TO
REACH THOSE GOALS AND THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE.
CRITICAL TO THAT.
ANOTHER PROGRAM NOT RELATED TO
WATER THAT WE ALSO PARTICIPATE
AND IN IS VERY POPULAR AND I
THINK HAS HAD A DRAMATIC EFFECT
FOR AGRICULTURE.
IS THE TRACTOR REPLACEMENT
PROGRAM OPERATED THROUGH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
AND THAT RECEIVES A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THROUGH THE I
BELIEVE IS THE FARMER --
PROGRAM THAT WAS RECENTLY
[inaudible]
BUDGETS.
THAT PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN
REPLACING SOME OF OUR OLDER
TRACTORS TRACTORS THAT WE'VE
USED ON OUR FARM --
SINCE BEFORE I WAS BORN --
BACK FROM SET SOME TRACTORS FROM
DATING FROM THE SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES DIESEL TRACTORS --
THAT WE AS FARMERS WE LIKE TO
KEEP EVERYTHING PATCHED TOGETHER
AND GO AS WHERE WHERE WHERE VERY
FRUGAL.
THAT THE AND THEY WERE NOT
REALLY AS LOW POLLUTING THERE
ARE A LOT OF TEARS ZERO TWO YEAR
ONE MOSTLY TEARS ZERO TRACTORS
AND THROUGH THIS TRACTOR
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM.
IT HELPS US INCENTIVIZE TO
UPGRADE OUR QUITMAN AND SO WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO REPLACE AND WE
SHOULD PROBABLY BY THE END OF
NEXT YEAR HAVE COMPLETELY
REPLACED OUR ENTIRE TRACTOR
FLEET. TO TIER THREE OR FOUR
TRACTORS AND THAT IS JUST ON OUR
FARM THAT PROGRAM IS SO
SUCCESSFUL.
THAT WE HAVE TO WAIT. TO GET THE
A THE APPROVAL FOR REPLACING
TRACTORS BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
MANY APPLICATIONS THERE'S MORE
APPLICATIONS NOT THE MONEY.
THEN PEOPLE ABLE TO PROCESS THE
APPLICATIONS SO WE'D HAVE WAITS
OF UP TO TWO YEARS JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S SUCH A HIGH VOLUME OF
AGRICULTURAL IS SEEKING TO
CHANGE THEIR TRACTORS.
AND SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EMISSIONS AND ON ON FARM AND OFF
FARMAN THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
NOW GOING FROM TWO ZERO TO TIER
THREE OR FOUR THAT YOU HAVE SUCH
AN INTEREST WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES.
I THINK THAT SAYS A LOT ABOUT
AGRICULTURE AND ITS INVESTMENT
IN.
PARTICIPATING IN PARTNERSHIPS TO
TO CLEAN UP --
THE AR INTO AND MODERNIZE OUR
FLEET OF EQUIPMENT --
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT WE'RE
ALL KIND OF BASICALLY IN THIS --
VALLEY TOGETHER AND THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TOGETHER WE WORK
TOGETHER AND NOT PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE STATE ON HELPING TO
INCENTIVIZE SHOWS THAT I THINK
THAT YOU CAN HAVE A LOT OF
POWERFUL INFLUENCE ON ON THE
ENVIRONMENT --
OTHER THAN THAT I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF OTHER SMALL ACTIVITIES
THAT HAPPEN ON THE FARM BUT MY
MY BIGGEST POINT IS IS I THINK
FOR LOOKING AT AGRICULTURE AND
ITS PARTICIPATION AND AND AND
TRYING -- TO
TO BE BETTER STEWARDS OF THE
LAND THAT WE FARM FOR SO LONG --
AS AS THE WORLD.
SENATE'S DEFINITELY HELP.
AGRICULTURE MAKE THE CHANGE TO
THE MODERN --
MODERN STANDARDS BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE A LARGE FARM.
IT'S EASY --
TO SPREAD THAT COST OUT OVER A
LARGE ACRES BUT FOR YOUR MID
SIZE AND SMALL FARMS LIKE MYSELF --
THE CHANGES ARE MUCH HARDER TO
MAKE AND SO THAT'S WHY I THINK
THESE PROGRAMS CAN HAVE EVEN
BAKER --
INCENTIVE TO HELP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY.
HI MY NAME IS PAUL BUTLER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION --
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND TALK
ABOUT.
THE RICE INDUSTRIES --
ENVIRONMENTAL RESUME --
JUST FOR A LITTLE BACKGROUND --
I SPENT OVER TEN YEARS WITH
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD AND
I'VE BEEN MANAGING ENVIRONMENTAL
AFFAIRS NOW TO RAISE COMMISSION
FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS --
GOING TO THE NEXT SLIDE.
HERE ARE JUST SOME SYMBOLS
REALLY OF THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THEM FOR
FOR DECADES OF COURSE BUT ON THE
LEFT SIDE I'M AND SCENE OF THE
MILLIONS OF WATERFOWL THAT COME
UP FROM THE RICE FIELDS AND THE
WINTER TIME --
WATERFOWL IN THE CENTER AND THEN
UP ABOVE WE HAVE A SHORE BIRD
THERE LONG BILLED CURLEW.
IT IS HIGHLY IMPERILED INTO THE
U. S. SHARPER CONSERVATION
PLANNING IT THRIVES WELL IN
CALIFORNIA RICE AND WE DIDN'T
BEEN DOING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK WITH OUR WATERBIRD
PARTNERS TO ENHANCE --
HABITAT FOR FOR THOSE BIRDS
ENOUGH IN THE UPPER RIGHT YOU
SEE THE GIANT GARTER SNAKE WHICH
IS A THREATENED SPECIES WHICH
THRIVED A WELL AND HAS ADAPTED
WELL -- TO
RICE INDUSTRY IN THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY IN FACT THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT IF RICE WASN'T
THERE THAT SNAKE MAY NOT BE THE
AROUND EITHER SO.
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU SEE THE
BEAUTIFUL BLUE CLEAR SKIES WHICH
FORMERLY THEY WANT SO CLEAR WE
BURNED ALL OF OUR RIGHTS STRONG.
WHO NO LONGER DOING THAT AND --
USING ALTERNATIVES TO DECOMPOSE
R. RICE STRAW.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE SEE A
SALMON WHICH I'LL TALK ABOUT IN
A FEW MOMENTS IT'S SORT OF THE
NEXT OF FRONTIER FOR US WE HOPE --
FOR IMPROVING HABITAT.
US SO THAT 97% OF THE OF THE
RICE IN IS GROWN RIGHT HERE IN
THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES ABOUT
FIVE BILLION. TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS TO THE ECONOMY. OH
WE GROW VIRTUALLY EVERY GRAIN OF
AMERICA'S SUSHI RICE --
THE REST OF THE U. S. GROWS A
PRIMARILY LONG GRAIN AND WE GROW
ALL OF THE SUSHI RICE.
A IN THE UNITED STATES AND OF
COURSE I WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
YIELDS IN THE WORLD --
WERE MUCH MORE ATER EFFICIENT
THAN YOU MIGHT IMAGINE TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT AS WELL.
AND OF COURSE WE HAVE A A VERY --
STRONG THIRTY YEAR HISTORY OF
MANAGING WATER AND AIR QUALITY
PROGRAMS --
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY --
RICE'S GROWN IN JUST FIVE INCHES
OF WATER A MANY PEOPLE THINK
IT'S MUCH DEEPER THAN THAT BUT
IT IS INDEED JUST FIVE INCHES --
WE USE --
GPS TECHNOLOGY TO LASER LEVEL
THOSE FIELDS US FLAT AS A TABLE
TOP SO THAT ALLOWS US TO MANAGE
WATER.
VERY VERY PRECISELY AND
EFFICIENTLY.
USING ABOUT THE SAME AMOUNT OF
WATER HAS ORANGES AND BROCCOLI
ALSO CONTRIBUTING TO EFFICIENCY
IS A RICE IS GROWN IN VERY HEAVY
CLAY SOILS.
THAT DO NOT PERCOLATE A WATER
MUCH AT ALL SO THEY'RE PERFECT
SORT OF BATHTUBS.
TO DOUBLE WATER VERY EFFICIENTLY --
BUT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY SPECIES
ARE USING THESE RICE FIELDS --
IF YOU IF THE RICE FIELDS WERE
NOT THERE A BUT YOU WANTED TO
PROVIDE.
THE SAME AMOUNT OF HABITAT TO
SUPPORT THE SAME NUMBER OF
WINTERING WATERFOWL ABOUT. SIX
MILLION DOCS YOU WOULD HAVE TO
ACQUIRE AND RESTORE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF OF
WEAPONS.
THAT WOULD COST YOU ABOUT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATE THEN YOU'D HAVE TO MAINTAIN
THOSE ACRES.
AT SOME PROBABLY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SO THERE'S JUST
ONE ONE SLICE OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT THAT IS
WINTERING WATERFOWL THAT WE CAN
QUANTIFY BECAUSE WE HAVE ALL THE
MODELING TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
WITH OUR PARTNERS.
OF ALL OF OUR RACE FIELDS ALONG
WITH THAT ROUGHLY SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES OF WETLANDS IN
THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY ARE
DESIGNATED AS SHOREBIRD HABITAT.
OF INTERNATIONAL SIGNIFICANCE
YOU CAN READ ABOUT THAT IT
MANAGEMENT DOT ORG --
AND WE HAVE A VERY VERY STRONG --
PARTNERSHIPS WITH A ALL THAT.
A LOT OF HOW CONSERVATION'S.
CONSERVATION GROUPS HERE --
AND FACT IN YOUR PACKET THAT
I'VE LEFT YOU THERE'S THAT
THERE'S AN INFORMATIONAL
DOCUMENT THAT SHOWS REALLY ALL
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS IN THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE IMPLEMENT
TOGETHER.
JUST A REALLY INTERESTING
GRAPHIC SHOWS YOU ABOUT 60% OF
EVERYTHING A DUCK EATS COMES OUT
OF RICE FIELDS ABOUT ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF WHAT THEY NEED IS
COMING FROM WETLANDS --
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH HALF OF
THAT WETLANDS PIE --
IS ALSO RELATED TO RIGHTS
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE RICE
FIELDS DON'T CONSUME ALL OF THE
WATER IN THE FIELDS THAT'S
DRAINED OFF AT THE END OF THE
SEASON --
ABOUT SEPTEMBER ONE OR SO.
AND ALL THAT WATER THAT STRAINED
OFF IS USED BY OTHER DOWNSTREAM
USES INCLUDING A HALF OF THE
WETLANDS FLAT UP WITH OUR TAIL
WATER -- BUT
BECAUSE IT'S RIGHT ABOUT THE
TIME THAT THEY NEED TO FLAT OUT
FOR TAXIS AND SO --
THE ENERGETICS AYE.
IS.
GOV OUT A DOUBLE THE WATERFOWL
THEIR IN THE VALLEY IN THE
WINTER.
ARE ARE VERY VERY RELIANT ON
RICE ACRES THEY'VE ADAPTED TO
THEM WHILE. 95% OF THE WETLANDS
ARE GONE AND SO MORE IN A
SITUATION WHERE THESE RICE
FIELDS ARE NOW UP.
YOU KNOW CARRYING LABORING MORE
FOR WATERFOWL.
AND JUST SEE.
WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS HERE'S A
COUPLE OF GRAPHICS --
IF 50% OF THE RICE FIELDS WERE
TO GO AWAY THEIR AB ONE MILLION
FEWER DUCKS.
KNOW WHEN OUR TIME HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY AND THAT'S
SUPPORTED BY THESE ENERGETICS
CURVES YOU SEE AT THE BOTTOM.
THE BOTTOM YOU CAN SEE THE THE
RED CURVE IS THE DUCK
POPULATIONS IN THE BLACK CURVE
IS FOOD WITHOUT RICE --
AT THE DOCKS EITHER STARVE OR
HAVE TO LEAVE THE AREA ABOUT
DECEMBER.
BUT WITH RICE SEE THAT BUT I'M
VERY HIGH BLACK CURVE.
OF THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE GROWERS
Y. THEY WOULD LOVE --
EVERY KERNEL OF RICE THEY LEAVE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS THREE HUNDRED POUNDS
BEHIND.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
DOCTOR AFTER --
HIGH CARBOHYDRATES TO PREPARE TO
GO UP AND HAVE VERY SUCCESSFUL A
NESTING.
SO WE HAVE A HAD A LOT OF
SUCCESS --
WITH OUR PARTNERS OF ATTRACTING
INCENTIVE DOLLARS --
FOR PROGRAMS --
IN YOUR PACKET IS THAT IS THAT
IS REALLY A CASE STUDY ABOUT A
PROGRAM THAT WE BUILT --
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA CALLED
AND THEY WATER BIRD HABITAT
HANSON PROGRAM WE CALL IT
WEAPONS --
WE EIGHT BASICALLY INVENTED --
FOUR FIVE UNIQUE PRACTICES THAT
WE KNEW THAT WE COULD THAT
INCREASE THE ECOSYSTEM BENEFIT
OF EACH ACRE OF RICE WITH THESE
PRACTICES.
AND SINCE THEN AND RCS HAS
CONTRIBUTED ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. TO ENHANCE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES OF RICE --
IN THAT TIME FRAME.
HOWEVER WHERE WE'RE STRUGGLING
TO HOLD ON TO THOSE PROGRAMS SO
SO FEDERAL FUNDING IS IS
DECLINING IN RECENT YEARS --
WE'VE NOT.
EVER TO THIS POINT HAD AS A
STATE PROGRAM REALLY THAT WAS
DEDICATED FOR THIS TYPE.
RICELAND HABITAT PURPOSES.
I AM.
VERY PLEASED TO REPORT THAT AP
AT TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT MS
CURRIE'S BILL.
WILL DO EXACTLY THAT AND THERE'S
A THERE'S A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME APPROPRIATION TO GET US
STARTED ON THAT.
AT THAT THAT GREAT STARDOM WILL
BE ABLE TO DO I BELIEVE MANY OF
THAT GREAT PRACTICES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED A A USING THOSE
FEDERAL FUNDS AND ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS I SEE ABOUT.
PUTTING MORE STATE FUNDS TO TO
TO A PROGRAM LIKE THIS IS THAT
ALLOWS US TO ATTRACT MORE
FEDERAL FUNDING IS EVERY TIME
YOU WANT.
TO GO APPLY FOR ONE OF THESE
PROGRAMS YOU NEED A NON FEDERAL
MATCHING.
ARE TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
A ANOTHER WAY THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO INCREASE OUR INVESTMENT.
IN THESE PRACTICES IS THE RICE
INDUSTRY HAS CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA ICELAND'S WATERBIRD
FOUNDATION --
WET WEBSITE IS PROMINENTLY THERE
FOR EVERYONE TO TO SEE --
IF YOU WANNA INVEST IN --
HABITAT IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
WE VERY EFFICIENTLY TAKE THOSE
DOLLARS.
WE WORK WITH OUR WATER BIRD
PARTNERS AND A OUR GROWERS AND
WE INCENTIVIZE THE GROWERS TO DO
THE ACTIONS THAT WE WANT THEM TO
DO IT EXACTLY THE TIME OF YEAR
WE WANT THEM TO DO TO PROVIDE
VERY SPECIFIC AND TARGETED
HABITAT.
AT A VERY COST EFFECTIVE RATE SO.
ANYONE THAT TO ONCE A TAX
DEDUCTIBLE DEDUCTION AND ALSO
OUR OWN AN ACRE HABITAT THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY THAT'S A GREAT
VEHICLE TO DO SO.
SUBMIT YOUR ON THAT CAN YOU TO
GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT THOSE
PRACTICES ARMY LIKE WHAT WHAT DO
YOU DO OKAY AND ARE JUST TO GIVE
US AN IDEA OF OKAY MIGHT TAKE A
COUPLE MINUTES BUT OF ONE OF THE
PRACTICES WE DO FOR EXAMPLE IS.
A GROWER IS MOST EFFICIENT AGRA
NAM AKELEY.
IF AT THE END OF THE WINTER
SEASON WHEN THAT MAYBE THEY'LL
GET THE FIELDS FLOODED THEY
TRAIN THEM OFF LIKE A FEBRUARY
ONE ALL AT THE SAME TIME SO IT
CAN DRY OUT THOSE FIELDS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T REALLY GET PLANTED.
MUSCLES FIELDS OF DRY.
WE ARE PRACTICE IT ENCOURAGES
THEM TO KEEP THAT WATER OUT
THERE LIKE TILL MID MARCH --
AND DRAIN THOSE FIELDS --
BY 25% A WEEK SO NOW THERE'S A
VARIETY OF SHOREBIRDS THAT COME
IN AND THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
NEEDS IN TERMS OF DEPTH OF WATER
SO.
I LIKE TO SAY A BIRD CAN COME ON
TO ONE FIREMAN FIND HOT BROW OF
DIFFERENT TO A DEPTH OF WATER.
TO UTILIZE WILL ALSO HAVE A
PRACTICE TO BRING WATER ON
EARLIER --
IN THE FALL AFTER HARVEST PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THIS BUT THE SHORE
BIRD MIGRATION HAS ALREADY
STARTED LIKE IN JULY LIKE IT'S
WRAPPING UP NOW IN THESE BIRDS
COMMAND.
THEY HAVE A HARD TIME FINDING
THAT OPEN SHALLOW WATER THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AND SO --
AGAIN IT'S MOST.
THAT ECONOMICALLY EFFICIENT FOR
AGO OUR DEBT --
HAVE HIS WHOLE TEAM WORK ON
NOTHING BUT HARVEST FOR LIKE
FIVE WEEKS.
BUT IF THEY CAN SOMEHOW START
WORKING ON GETTING WATER ON THE
FIRST HALF OF THEIR FIELD WHILE
THEY'RE STILL HARVESTING THE
LAST PART WE CAN GET SOME WATER
ON A EARLY AND IT'S VERY
VALUABLE FOR THE SHORE BIRDS.
IT'S ALSO NESTING ISLANDS IN A
VARIETY OF OTHER PRACTICES THAT
I COULD DO IT [inaudible]
I'M.
SO THIS IS WHAT WE HOPE TO BE
THE NEW FRONTIER --
FOR US A WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
REALLY THINK ABOUT THE CONCEPTS
WE'VE DONE FOR BIRDS WE'VE WE'VE
ESSENTIALLY REKLAME TO THE THE
THE FLOOD PLAIN FOR BIRDS JUST
AS THEY USED HISTORICALLY.
EXCEPT NOW WE FLY THEM IN RICE
FIELDS UNDER VERY CONTROLLED
SITUATIONS AND THE BIRDS ARE
USING ESSENTIALLY THE SAME LANDS
THEY DID HISTORICALLY.
WELL YOU KNOW WE MAY BE ABLE TO
DO THIS WITH FISH.
TOO OUR BECAUSE THE REASON WE
HAVE A SALMON RUNS IN CALIFORNIA
IS LARGELY BECAUSE THOSE SMALL
SALMON FRY ORIGINALLY GREW UP IN
THE FLOOD PLAINS OF THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY.
WHERE THERE WAS VERY LITTLE FLOW
VERY FEW PREDATORS ALLOTTED
COVER AND THOSE THE FACT THAT
THAT WATER JUST SITS THAT
RECEIVES ALL THAT SOLAR ENERGY
AND THE PHYTOPLANKTON SO
PLANKTON CYCLE?
IT FEEDS THE THOSE THOSE FISH.
AND THEY GROW VERY.
AGGRESSIVELY HISTORICALLY THEY
WERE PUSHED BACK INTO THE MAIN
CHANNEL THE RIVER AFTER THEY
WERE LARGE ENOUGH.
TO AND YOU KNOW BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THOSE FLOWS AND EVADE
PREDATORS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
NOW WE'VE ESSENTIALLY SEALED OFF
THE RIVER FROM THE FLOOD PLAIN
AND THE SMALL FISH HAVE TO SORT
OF FIGHT FOR THEIR LIVES RIGHT
IN THE MAIN CHANNEL THE RIVER.
SO NOW WE ARE LOOKING AT SEEING
IF WE CAN --
UTILIZE WINTER FLOODED RICE
FIELDS EXACTLY THAT WAY ACTUALLY
PUT THE SALMON IN THE RICE
FIELDS.
AND HAVE THEM GROW A VERY VERY
QUICKLY THERE'S A PROJECT WE'VE
DONE -- FOR
THAT HAS BEEN DONE FARE FOR OVER
FIVE YEARS CALLED AN EERIE
PROJECT WHERE WE'VE DEMONSTRATED
THAT THE GROWTH RATES.
ARE EVER EXTREMELY HIGH I IN
RICE FIELDS IN THE WINTER TIME
SO WE'RE GONNA TRY TO REPLICATE
THAT.
WE ALSO MAY BE ABLE --
TO DOT EXPORT HIGHLY NUTRITIOUS
WATER BACK INTO THE RIVER FROM
THE RICE FIELDS WHICH I'LL TALK
ABOUT IN A MINUTE.
HERE YOU SEE OUT SOME PICTURES
OF WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT SO ON
THE UPPER RIGHT ARE THE LITTLE
MICROSCOPIC CRITTERS THAT THESE
YOUNG SALMON NEED.
AND THEY'RE VERY PLENTIFUL IN
RICE FIELDS WINTER FLOODED RICE
FIELD OF THE LOWER CORNER SHOWS
YOU.
A MANY MANY OF THOSE YOU KNOW
PER DROP IN IN WINTER FLOODED
RICE WATER.
AND SO IF WE CAN.
GET THE FISH TO THAT AND THEN
HAVE THEM FIND THEIR WAY BACK TO
THE RIVER THAT'S ONE CONCEPT OR
WEAKENED.
MORE --
PURPOSEFULLY EXPORT THAT WATER
INTO THE RIVER AND FEED THEM IN
THE RIVER.
SO THERE'S TWO APPROACHES THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT MAKING SOME
PROGRESS ON WE ARE.
RIGHT NOW IN THE MIDST OF TRYING
TO DEVELOP A PROJECT I DON'T
HAVE IT YET BUT I DO HAVE
COMMITMENT FROM AN RC*. FOR
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IF WE CAN PUT THE
PROJECT TOGETHER.
OUT WE WOULD ACTUALLY OUTPUT OF
THE FISH IN THE RICE FIELD AND
PUT LITTLE RADIO TAGS IN THEM
AND TRACK THEM ALL THE WAY OUT
THE GOLDEN GATE.
WE WOULD DO THE SAME THING FOR
THE FISH THAT HAVE TO STAY IN
THE RIVER.
AND WE BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
DEMONSTRATION IF THE RICE FIELDS
REARED FISH ACTUALLY SURVIVE AT
HIGHER PERCENTAGE.
A OUT THE GOLDEN GATE VERY
EXCITING SCIENCE.
WILL ALSO BE PUTTING A FEW
THOUSAND FISH AND IN THE FIELDS
PER ACRE AND HAVING THE GROWER
MANAGED TO HABITAT TO OUR
SPECIFICATIONS. TO SEE IF WE CAN
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PRACTICE
STANDARD. FOR THIS ACTIVITY THAT
COULD BE FUNDED. FOR A FROM A
PROGRAM LIKE EQUIPED NRCS WE
HAVE ROW REYES SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
MATCHING DONOR FUNDS SO FAR.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO MATCH AT
LEAST.
ONE TO ONE OF THE SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM AN RCA
BECHTEL END UP BEING PROBABLY
ABOUT A ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT SO THERE'S ROOM
ON THE BANDWAGON FOR ANYBODY
THAT WANTS.
TO A JOINT IN.
AND WERE CURRENTLY LIP SORT OF
THE LAST PIECE WE'VE GOT ITS
DURING TALKS WITH.
A DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND ABOUT THEIR
CRITICAL ROLE OF PROVIDING US
THESE FISH FROM THE HATCHERY --
SO AS SOON AS WE GET DOWN --
SOME UNDERSTANDING AS TO WHEN
AND HOW THEY CAN PARTICIPATE AT
THAT LEVEL ALLUVIAL TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS EXCITING
PROJECT.
THAT'S IT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND WE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHE DID WELL WILL FINISH THE
PANEL AND THEN WE'LL COME BACK
AND SEE WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
BUT I THAT SALMON PROJECT IS
VERY EXCITING.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT.
THE COLLAPSE BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN DROUGHT WE SEE THE
COLLAPSE OF CERTAIN.
SALMON RUNS AND SO THE ABILITY
TO BRING IT BACK AND TO SET UP A
NEW MODEL IS VERY EXCITING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER LANCE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MICHAEL LINES ON THE DIRECTOR
OF PUBLIC POLICY FOR A LOT OF ON
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS THE STATE BRANCH FOR
THE NATIONAL AUDUBON SOCIETY.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CHANCE TO COME SPEAK TODAY AND
TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THE BENEFITS
THAT WE SEE FROM AGRICULTURE.
PARTICULARLY TO BIRDS BUT TO
OBTAIN VOMIT LARGE GIVEN I THINK
THE REALLY PRODUCTIVE AND
POSITIVE COMMENTS ABOUT A VAN
PROVIDED BY CAL CAN AND OTHERS
PAUL CERTAINLY.
THE OTHER PRETTY BURKE PICTURES
I SHOULD STONE SOME OF THOSE
MAKE IT WILL COME UP FOR US.
PAT.
I I DON'T REPEAT THOSE BUT I DO
WANT TO SERVE --
EMPHASIZE OUR SUPPORT FOR THAT
FOR THE NOTIONS OF A COW CAM IS
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT CLIMB AS
MUCH STRATEGIES ON FARMS HEALTH
FARMS ALREADY ARE BETTER.
AT HAD --
RETAINING --
CARBON AND OTHER GHG BENEFITS
NOT ALSO I NON JONASSAINT BY
MODERNIZING SOME OF MACHINERY
THAT'S OUT THERE THAT'S I MEAN
AUDUBON'S CONTINUE TO SUPPORT.
AND I THINK WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO A COUPLE POINTS THAT HEARD
ALREADY AND THESE ARE THINGS I'M
GONNA TOUCH ON WHICH OUR THEY
NEED ONE TO MIMIC WHAT WE CAN
NATURAL PROCESSES AND THAT'S
BOTH.
A WETLAND AREAS AND AS WELL AS
FOR ABOUT THE FISH I THINK IT'S
AN EXCITING NEW OPPORTUNITIES.
THEY'RE OUT THERE THAT WE NEED
TO PURSUE AND WE NEED TO INVEST
IN.
AND AND ALONG THE LINES OF
INVESTING IS THIS NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
INCENTIVIZE LAND OWNERS AND
FARMERS TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS.
A LOT OF THESE YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THE PROGRAMS IS JOHN IS
INDICATING YOU KNOW THEY'RE
ALREADY WORKING ON A MARGINAL
SCALE ABOUT HOW FARMS HOW
PROFITABLE FARMS CAN BE IN THE
MARKET DRIVEN.
AND SO IF WE AS A COMMUNITY AS A
STATE ONE INVEST IN THEM AND AND
HELP DEVELOP NEW PROGRAMS THAT
WE NEED TO PROVIDE FUNDING
SOURCES THAT'LL HELP DURHAM.
LINED US UP AND THEN THE LAST
PIECE REALLY IS TRYING TO
PROVIDE FOR INFORMATION SHARING
AND EDUCATION WHETHER THAT'S
CONNECTING --
REGULATORS AND AGENCIES AND
POSITIVELY IF OF LANDOWNERS OR
NGOS PROVIDING A CONDUIT BETWEEN
DIFFERENT LANDOWNERS WHO CAN
SHARE PRACTICES INFORMATION.
SO TO START IN THIS IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A REPEAT FROM WHAT --
PAUL WAS TALKING ABOUT WHY WOULD
A CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION LIKE
AUDUBON BE ENGAGED IN WORKING
LANDS PROGRAM WE WOULD ACT
WORKING.
AND ACROSS THE NATION.
WELL IN CALIFORNIA ALONE --
THERE'S AT LEAST SEVEN MILLION
ACRES OF IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE.
AND BUT THERE'S ONLY AN
ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PART MANAGED WETLANDS LEFT.
SO NATURALLY PRIOR TO NINETEEN
HUNDRED THERE WERE PROBABLY FOUR
MILLION ACRES OR SO OF NATURAL
FLOOD PLAIN WETLANDS IN THE
STATE THEIR IMMENSELY DIVERSE.
EARLIER EXPLORERS RECORDED THAT
THEY WOULD WITH A HELP WITH
THEIR WILD FIRES WERE ACTUALLY
BIRDS JUST COMING OFF THE
WETLANDS IN SUCH NUMBERS THAT
THEY BLOTTED OUT THE SUN.
AND SO WE CERTAINLY HAVE MANY
FEWER OF A WETLAND ACRES LEFT
TODAY AND LIKEWISE ARE BIRD
POPULATIONS HAVE DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY AS WELL.
PAUL MENTIONED THAT TIME --
WE HAVE --
FIVE TO SEVEN MILLION ACRES
VIBES FIVE SEVEN MILLION
WATERFOWL THAT USE THE STATE
EVERY YEAR THAT'S A NUMBER
THAT'S PROBABLY DOWN FROM THIRTY
TO FORTY MILLION.
HISTORICALLY LIKEWISE THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SHOREBIRD THREE
AND FIFTY THOUSAND SHOREBIRDS --
PROBABLY WAS WELL OVER THREE
MILLION AT ONE TIME HISTORICALLY
SO FROM A CONSERVATION.
ORGANIZATION WE UNDERSTAND THE
BIRDS ARE DECLINE GRASSLAND
BURNED AS WELL AS WELL TOUCH ON
THAT WITH RANCHING.
A AND THAT IN ORDER TO HAVE LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY AND
CONSERVATION OF THE SPECIES NOT
JUST BIRDS BUT ALL THE OTHER
SPECIES AS WELL.
THEN THAT REQUIRES COLLABORATION
AND PARTNERSHIP WITH FARMERS AND
LANDOWNERS AND OTHERS THAT ARE
STEWARDING LARGETRACTS OF LAND
IN THE STATE.
ARE THE LAST THING I'LL ARE JUST
WILL NOTICE THAT WE'VE ALSO IN
RECENT YEARS BECOME MORE MORE
AWARE OF THE NECESSITY.
FOR NATURAL WORKING LANDS AS
PART OF OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
STRATEGY NOT JUST IN
SEQUESTERING CARBON BUT ALSO
PROVIDING WILDLIFE CORRIDORS AND
SOME DEGREE OF RESILIENCE FOR
NATIVE PLANTS AND NATIVE
WILDLIFE.
AS THE LANDSCAPE OVERALL CHANGES
AND I THINK THAT WILDLIFE
CORRIDOR IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT.
AT LEAST THOUGHT OF ON AND THOSE
OF US WORKING ON TRUST JAIL
TAXES.
SO WHAT OF ONE CREATED TO
TWERKING LANCE PROGRAM WITH A
VISION OF HELPING TO CREATE WITH
IN CALIFORNIA.
A MATRIX OF WORKING LANDS AND
MANAGED WETLANDS PROVIDE FOR
THIS LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE.
CONSERVATION AND IS EXECUTED TWO
ON THE GROUND STAFF WE HAVE --
SEVENTY THOUSAND ACRES OF LAND.
OPERATE INCLUDING A ACT OF
CATTLE RANCH OUTSIDE OF WINTERS
AS WELL AS BIOLOGISTS AN ANALYST
TO GO OUT TO WORK WITH PARTNERS
LIKE PAUL AND THE LANDOWNERS.
AND WHAT WE TRY TO DO ON OUR
LAND AND OTHER IS DEVELOP PILOT
PROJECTS THAT CAN BE SCALED UP
FOR LAND MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT PAUL
PARTY MENTIONED.
AND I WANNA MENTION AND
EMPHASIZE WE DON'T DO THAT ALLOW
NOT ONLY IS THE PARTNERS --
AMONG FARMERS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES BUT ALSO WE'RE
PART THE MIGRATORY BIRD
CONSERVATION PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE NATURE OF WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND POINT BLUE
CONSERVATION SCIENCE.
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN IMMENSE
WORK DONE BY OTHER PARTNERS
INCLUDING DUCKS UNLIMITED IN
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL.
AND MANY OTHERS THAT ARE TRYING
TO WORK ON THIS NOTION OF THE
MATRIX OF MANAGED AND NATURAL
LANDS.
SO TODAY WE'VE HAD SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS DURING THE
DROUGHT WHEN HABITAT WAS
SHRINKING ALL AROUND US WE STILL
MANAGE TO WORK WITH PARTNERS TO
SECURE A HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES
OF IRRIGATED CROPLAND.
THAT PROVIDED ACT OF HABITAT FOR
WATERFOWL AND AND SHORE BIRDS
THAT WERE REALLY STRESSED DURING
THIS PROLONGED DROUGHT.
AND WE DID THAT IN PART WITH AN
INVESTMENT OF OF OVER FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WENT TO THE
LANDOWNERS IN ORDER TO HELP THEM
MAKE THAT HAPPEN FOR THE KIND OF
PRACTICES THE PAUL ALREADY
MENTIONED.
I WE'VE ALSO --
AND ENGAGE THOUSANDS OF
LANDOWNERS TO SHARE RESOURCES
AND CONNECT WITH EACH OTHER LAND
OWNERSHIP DIDN'T KNOW EACH OTHER
PRIOR TO WORKSHOPS AND OTHER
TRAINING SESSIONS.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW THEM TO TRADE
INFORMATION ON WHAT WHAT IS WORK
ON THEIR LANDS BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO KNOW BEST THAT THE
ONES MANAGING THOSE LANDS.
AND SHARE INFORMATION ON
RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE THE KIND
OF GRANTS AND FUNDING --
JOHN MENTIONED EARLIER. TWO
OTHER SPECIFIC EXAMPLES I'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE THAT ARE RECENT AND
HAVE I THINK DEMONSTRATED HOW
NGOS AND THE COMMUNITY COURT
TOGETHER.
A THE FIRST IS WITH THE ROBINS
RICE COMPANY AND AUDUBON CREATED
THE FIRST EVER AND BURKE FAMILY
RICE CERTIFICATION PROGRAM.
AND NOW ROBIN'S RICE ACTUALLY
HAS A LABEL THAT THEY PUT HOW
FOR MARKETING ON THEIR RACE
PRODUCTS.
AND THEY DIDTHAT IN
CONSULTATION WITH US TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE PROJECT OTHER
PRODUCT ALL THE WAY FROM THE
GROUND TO TO PROCESSING WAS AS
BIRD FAMILY AS POSSIBLE.
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONTINUE TO
WORK IN THAT KIND OF PARTNERSHIP
TOGETHER TO HELP BOOST THEIR
SALES AND ALSO.
CREATE A A PIPELINE OF
SUSTAINABILITY IN THEIR IN THEIR
PRODUCT.
THE LAST ONE IS A LITTLE MORE
CONTROVERSY ON NOW BUT RECENTLY
THE TRI COLOR BLACK BIRD WAS
LISTED AS AN ENDANGERED SPECIES
IN THE STATE.
AND AUDUBON WORKED VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE FARM BUREAU AND THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY AND EVEN THOUGH
WE DISAGREED AS TO WHETHER THAT
SPECIES SHOULD BE LISTED AS
ENDANGERED OR NOT.
EVEN DURING I'D SAY MAYBE THE
MOST CONTENTIOUS PARTS OF THAT
DEBATE AROUND THE SPECIES THERE
WAS STILL A VERY STRONG AND
PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
AUDUBON.
AND THE DAIRY INDUSTRY AND THE
FARM BUREAU AND THEY REALLY
STEPPED UP TO GO OUT AND EDUCATE
LANDOWNERS.
AND TRY TO WORK ON IN OUR CS
PROGRAM WHICH WE SUCCESSFULLY
USED AS WELL AS LEVERAGING
PRIVATE.
HOME FUNDING IN SOME OF OUT OF
ONE'S OWN FUNDING.
WHO ARE BURDENED BY HAVING THIS
SHE'S ON THE LAND AND THEY WERE
TRYING?
TO HARVEST THEIR CROPS TO FEED
THEIR COWS.
AND SO I THINK THAT IS AN
EXAMPLE ON THAT WE CONTINUE TO
BE PROUD AT AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON NOT ONLY ON TRICOLOR
BLACKBIRD BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE EVEN OF THE
SPECIES IS STILL.
LISTED BUT IN ORDER IN THE
FUTURE TO TRY TO FIND FUNNY
MONEY TO INCENTIVIZE HE'S KIND
OF PROJECTS.
THAT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE THAT WENT
WHERE EVEN SOMETHING IS AS
CONTENTIOUS IS AN ENDANGERED
SPECIES THERE CAN STILL BE A LOT
OF ROOM TO WORK NOT OF MINE AND
MANY OTHER NGOS ARE TRYING TO
FIND WAYS TO REDUCE THE BURDENS
ON LANDOWNERS.
BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IS
TO INCENTIVIZE LANDOWNERS TO
INVITE THIS SPECIES ON THEIR
LAND AND MAINTAIN THEM SO WE CAN
DO SAFE HARBOR PROJECT PROJECTS
AND REGULATIONS.
AND AND OR SOME OTHER SORT OF
AVENUES THAT WE CAN PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF TO LANDOWNERS ON LOOKING
FORWARD I THINK WE'VE ALL TALKED
ABOUT THE CLIMATE CHANGE THE
IMMENSE CHALLENGES. FOR SPECIES
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE THERE'S AT
LEAST A HUNDRED EIGHTY SPECIES
THAT ARE MORE LIKELY TO GO AT
LEAST TOWARD EXTINCTION.
CLIMATE CHANGE OVER THE NEXT
EIGHTY YEARS SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE CLIMATE CHANGES OR
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT FOR A LOT
OF SPECIES.
AND NOW WE SEE ADDITIONAL
PRESSURES ON FARMLAND AND
NATURAL LANCE'S WAS ALREADY
DISCUSSED.
OBVIOUSLY WATER SUPPLY
CHALLENGES WILL.
SINGLE GROUNDWATER BUT AGAIN AS
DROUGHTS ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
PROLONGED HOW WE GOING.
TO PROVIDE THAT WATER TO
DIFFERENT LAND USES AND ALSO
PROVIDE FOR BY DIVERSITY.
AND THEN POPULATION GROWTH AND
AND IT'S KIND OF URBAN EXPANSION
INTO NATURAL AND WORKING LANCE
IS A HUGE CONCERN.
IT'S JUST SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE SEEK TO WORK ON
THOSE AND I'VE MENTION THESE BUT
I WANNA MAKE SURE WE HAD A HIT
ON THEM JUST FOR FOR I'VE
STOPPED HERE WHICH IS.
ONE LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE FUNDING TO ASSIST
FARMERS AND RANCHERS --
A TO KEEP DOING WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND ALSO WHERE POSSIBLE TO
IMPROVE PRACTICES EITHER FOR THE
KIND OF GHQ BENEFITS MATT.
MANAGE HOWEVER MENTIONED ALREADY
OR INCREASING BURKE FAMILY
PRACTICES --
WE WANT TO TRY TO FIND A
BALANCED WATER SUPPLY MANAGER
PROGRAM THAT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IF THAT
DOESN'T AND THERE'S A LOT MORE
CONTENTION.
FIGHTING OVER THAT VERY OFTEN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND BERGSON
HABITAT A GOING TO LOSE FIRST.
AND SO IT'S IN OUR INTEREST TO
TRY TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE THOSE
THINGS WORK TOGETHER --
AND THE LAST PIECE I WANTED TO
MENTION WAS REALLY ON FINING
KELABIT SOLUTIONS AGAIN ON
SPECIAL STATUS SPECIES --
WHEREVER POSSIBLE TO SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENTS IN THESE KIND OF
FUNDING INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BY
NRCS [inaudible]
LASTLY I BUT THERE'S A LOT OF ON
IS A SCIENCE BASED ORGANIZATION
WANTS TO EMPHASIZE THAT WITH ALL
THESE MATCH PRACTICES ALSO
BECOMES A NEED. TO INVEST IN
SCIENCE.
AND WHEN WE CAN DO MY MONEY
TRAIN IN ADDITIONAL SCIENTIFIC
INVESTMENTS WE CAN FIND WAYS TO
MANAGE THE TIMING AND MANAGEMENT
OF THINGS LIKE WATER LIKE PAUL
MENTIONED ABOUT WHEN THAT SHOULD
GO ON THE LANDSCAPE. TO MAXIMIZE
BENEFITS TO SPECIES WILL ALSO
REDUCING THE BURN THE BURDENS ON
THE LANDOWNERS.
AND I THINK WHEN WE DO THAT WE
ACTUALLY FIND WAYS TO REDUCE
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS BETWEEN
CONSERVATIONISTS AND THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR.
THANK YOU WRITTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY HELPFUL.
WHATEVER GO.
FOR THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MICHAEL BOCA DORAN I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR GARY CARES AND HAVE FOR
ABOUT THE LAST TWENTY YEARS.
A ITS OUR INDUSTRY COALITION
THAT INVOLVES THE ENTIRE DAIRY
INDUSTRY THAT WORKS EXCLUSIVELY
ON SUSTAINABILITY ISSUES SO.
I'M REALLY GONNA FOCUS TODAY ON
SOME OF THE METHANE REDUCTION
EFFORTS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
TREMENDOUS STORY.
AND THEN BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THE OTHER EXTENSIVE
SUSTAINABILITY PROJECTS THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS WORKING ON OUR DAIRY
METHANE REDUCTION STRATEGY IS --
MEUM BEEN WIDELY DISCUSSED IN IN
THE LEGISLATURE THE LAST FEW
YEARS -- BUT
WE HAVE A A REALLY GOOD.
PLACE AND IT'S BASED ON THREE
PRIMARY APPROACHES AND THAT'S
COOPERATING WITH THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE CPUC.
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT THAT THAT'S A
VERY PRODUCTIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIP.
RIGHT NOW WITH THREE PRIMARY
INITIATIVES RESEARCH.
NOTHING AVOIDANCE AND METHANE
CAPTURING HIM TO TALK ABOUT BOTH
OF THOSE.
AND THEN.
THIS IS ALL MADE POSSIBLE YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT TODAY ABOUT
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS AND I CAN
TELL YOU THIS WOULD NOT BE
WORKING EXCEPT FOR THE FACT THAT.
SENATOR LARA WINNIE CRAFTED
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE RECOGNIZE
AND SENATE BATES PROGRAM WAS
GOING TO BE NECESSARY HERE.
AND THE GOVERNOR AND THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS STEPPED UP OVER
THE PASSPORT BUDGET CYCLE SOME
PROVIDED TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO CDFA FOR
DAIRY METHANE REDUCTION.
SO IT'S A REAL STRAIGHT FORWARD
APPROACH AND IT'S WORKING WELL --
SO JUST ON THE RESEARCH SIDE
WHERE WE'RE DOING A LOT WORKING
WITH CDFA INNER BE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND EMISSIONS TO YOU
CAN'T CONTROL WHAT YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND AND WE'VE NOT ONLY
WORKED WITH THERE BEING CDFA
WE'VE WORKED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND ANOTHER PRIVATE
ENTITIES. TO TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND A A REPORT WILL BE PUBLISHED
SOON FROM EDF LOOKING AT THAT
SOME OF THE AREAS WERE VERY
EMISSIONS CURVE.
WE'RE WORKING TO QUANTIFY THE
BENEFITS THE TECHNOLOGIES FOR IN
THE FIELD NOW DOCTOR FRANK MET
LONER FROM UC DAVIS TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THE ALTERNATE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AND
QUANTIFY.
THOSE BENEFITS WERE LOOKING FOR
OTHER METHANE REDUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES CONSTANTLY AND
THEN WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING. TO
MAKE SURE AND AND VALIDATE.
WHAT IT IS WORK COMP PUSHING AND
SO?
IT'S A GREAT STORY THE AMP
PROGRAM HAS NOW FUNDED EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS.
ARE THERE GOING TO BE FUNDING
PROBABLY AT LEAST ANOTHER FORTY
MORE HERE IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
WE EXPECT THEM TO BE ANNOUNCED
BY CDFA THIS MONTH --
SO I IT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAM ARTIST AT SOME OF THE
HIGH POINTS MORE THAN --
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND TOTAL
METRIC TONS OF CO TWO WE JUST
FROM THOSE FIRST EIGHTEEN
PROJECTS --
WE EXPECT.
AND THAT THESE PROJECTS AND WILL
HAVE AT LEAST A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY OF THEM OPERATING BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO VERY FAST
RAMP UP.
FROM EIGHTEEN IN THE INITIAL
ROUND MAYBE AS MANY AS A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND AT THAT.
BASED ON CURRENT ESTIMATES ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION METRIC
TONS OF CO TWO WE OVER A TEN
YEAR LIFE CYCLE.
AS IT'S VERY TREMENDOUS AND
THESE ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED ON
VERY SMALL DAIRIES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY CALS TO SOME VERY LARGE
DAIRIES OF SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN A KIND OF RUN THE
GAMUT OF CONVERTING FROM FLESH
TO SCRAPE.
SOME PASTOR BASED PROGRAMS AND
THEN THE EXTENSIVE USE OF SOLID
SEPARATION ON SOME OF THESE
DAIRIES.
THAT TO LIMIT THE AMOUNT OF OF
NOTHING THAT GOES.
AMOUNT OF THE NEWER THAT GOES
INTO A LOOK AND AMOUNT OF
METHANE IT PRODUCES.
THE DEBATE I JUST A PROGRAM IS A
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS STORY AS WELL --
SIXTY FOUR PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
FUNDED TO DATE ACHIEVING
ESTIMATED REDUCTIONS OF THIRTEEN
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CO TWO E.
OVER THIRTEEN YEARS.
THE COST OF THOSE REDUCTIONS ARE
JUST TWENTY SEVEN DOLLARS PORTAL
ALL IN.
AND THE COST OF THE STATE IS
JUST. EIGHT DOLLARS A METRIC TON.
SO IT IS THE THIRD MOST COST
EFFECTIVE INVESTMENT THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THIS GOVERNMENT
IS MAKING WITH THE GT R. F.
FUNDS.
AND AS A OR B. REPORTED IN THEIR
LAST REPORT IT'S THE NUMBER ONE
MOST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM IN
ACHIEVING TOTAL GHG REDUCTIONS.
AND IT'S ALL NOTHING WHICH MEANS
WE'RE GONNA SEE THE BENEFITS OF
IT MUCH SOONER THAN OTHER CO TWO
REDUCTION PROGRAMS SO.
SO THAT THAT.
STATISTICS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT NUMBER.
AND THAT THE WHOLE REASON FOR
THE HEARING QUITE FRANKLY IS
THAT.
AS WE DISCUSSED.
CAP AND TRADE.
AND SPENDING AND WHERE IT SHOULD
GO AND HOW IT SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED --
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT WE LOST
THE MORE LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
OF THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T FEEL THAT IT WAS
GOING TO GET THE MOST BANG FOR
ITS BUCK OR TOO MUCH WAS GOING
TO AGRICULTURE.
BUT I I AM.
THIS IS WHY THIS HEARING BECOMES
REAL IMPORTANT BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
HOW IMPORTANT AGRICULTURE IS TO
OUR?
REDUCTION GOALS AND HOW IF WE
PARTNER.
WE CAN TAKE CARE OF SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
AT A REALLY COST EFFECTIVE.
ABOUT RATE SO I AFFECTING QUEUE
OUR THAT YEAH AND WERE WERE ALL
ABOUT THE STATISTICS BECAUSE
THEY'RE JUST SO.
ARE OVERWHELMING IN TERMS OF
WHAT IT'S ACHIEVING.
I ENDED SUGGEST THAT WE SHOULD
BE DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT
INVESTMENT NOT BACKING OFF AS WE
GO WELL AND WAS AS I PUT IT
PROBABLY SHOULD ADD AS A
FOOTNOTE THAT IT WAS DIFFICULT
FOR BOTH ENDS OF OUR CAUCUSES.
AND IN THE END SOME OF THE
REPUBLICANS PAID A PRICE FOR
BEING SUPPORTERS AS WELL SO THAT
IT.
IT BECAUSE IT HIT RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE AND THERE WERE A LOT OF
AYE SUPPORTING IT WAS DIFFICULT
FOR OUR CAN BOTH ENDS OF OUR ARE
ORGANIZATIONS. TO TO COME
ONBOARD SO THIS STATE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
ISSUE IT IT'S TREMENDOUS AND
JUST A FEW YEARS AGO WE HAD
TWELVE PROJECTS AND BY TWENTY
TWENTY TO GIVEN THE CURRENT
LEVELS OF FUNDING THAT ARE FOR
READY BEEN APPROPRIATED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
WE EXPECT TO HAVE AS MANY AS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY PROJECTS ON
PREDICTS A TENFOLD INCREASE.
IN JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS AND
MOST OF THESE NEW PROJECTS ARE
OF THE RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
VARIETY NOT THE ELECTRICITY
PRODUCTION VARIETY.
WHICH MEANS ARE ALSO GOING TO BE
PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION FEEL.
THAT WILL REPLACE DIESEL AND
WE'LL SEE CRITERIA POLLUTANT
REDUCTIONS.
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN THE
SOUTH COAST AND OTHER
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AROUND
THE STATE SO IT'S GOT THAT ADDED
BENEFIT THAT WILL ALSO BE
QUANTIFYING.
THE MAP JUST SHOWS YOU THE
TREMENDOUS PROGRESS THE CITY
EIGHTY PRODUCTS IN THE STATE
THAT ARE.
EITHER OPERATING ON VARIOUS
STAGES OF PRODUCTION WHERE
THEY'RE LOCATED THERE'S A HEAVY
CONCENTRATION IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND THINK MISTER SALAS IS
LEFT BUT AT A BIG OF CLUSTER AYE
IN KERN COUNTY AS WELL.
IN TERMS OF SOME OF THESE EARLY
PROJECTS.
SO JUST TO SUMMARIZE THE METHANE
REDUCTION EFFORTS --
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY BECAME THE
NATION'S LEADER IN DERRY METHANE
REDUCTION WE PASS THE OTHER
STATES I DON'T THINK IT'LL BE
LONG BEFORE WE PASSED THE Q.
MOTIVE.
OF ALL THE OTHER STATES.
ARE TO BE GIVEN THAT THE PACE
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON THIS IT'S
A CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
INVESTMENT PROGRAM IS YOU'VE
ALREADY STATED MADAM CHAIR.
WE'RE JUST GETTING STARTED IN
SHOWING THE ENTIRE WORLD HAD
JERRY CAN BE PART OF A GLOBAL
SUSTAINABLE FOOD SYSTEM.
AND WE ARE MOST IMPORTANTLY ON
PATH TO ACHIEVE THE 40%
REDUCTION --
THAT THE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS PROGRAM IS LOOKING
FOR AND MANEUVER METHANE
EMISSIONS AND DAMN HOPEFULLY.
WHEN CARP DOES A REPORT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO I WILL BE
25230% OF THE WAY THEY'RE SO
IT'S A --
I'M AGAIN --
A SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT REAL
BRIEFLY SOME OF THE OTHER DAIRY
SUSTAINABILITY EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTING
ACROSS THE STATE.
ARM WATER USE EFFICIENCY IS A
BIG AREA OF FOCUS FORCES WALL
WERE WORKING WITH DRIP
IRRIGATION ON TWENTY FARMS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE.
ON FOOD CROPS ALFALFA ANOTHER
FEED CROPS AND IT'S SHOWING UP
TO A 40% WATER SAVINGS.
AND IN SOME CASES NOT JUST WATER
SAVINGS BUT INCREASED YIELDS --
ENERGY USE EFFICIENCIES A BIG
AREA THIS IS ONE OF THAT THE
GOOD THINGS THAT P. JEANNIE DOES
WHEN THEY'RE NOT BURNING DOWN --
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA OTHER
HELPING.
THERE ACHIEVING UP 220%
REDUCTIONS --
IN ENERGY USE EFFICIENCY --
AND THAT'S A COOPERATIVE PROGRAM
THAT WE WORK WITH BOTH PGD IN
EDISON ON OUR ELECTRIFYING A LOT
OF EQUIPMENT A FEED MIXERS AND
IRRIGATION PUMPS THAT'S ALSO
PROVIDING SUBSTANTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
ON A RENEWABLE ENERGY STANDPOINT
I THINK THE DAIRY INDUSTRY IS IS
WAY OUT IN FRONT WITH MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED FARMS HAVING
INSTALLED.
A SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS AND THAT
NUMBER KEEPS GROWING IN A LOT OF
THAT WAS MADE POSSIBLE BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATURE.
HAD THE FORESIGHT TO ALLOW US TO
AGGREGATE --
IN THE NET ENERGY METERING
PROGRAM WHICH REALLY MADE THOSE
PROJECTS.
VIABLE FOR WATER QUALITY
STANDPOINT R. DAIRIES OPERATE
UNDER VERY STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS AND WILL BE MAKING
FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS THAT
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE INDUSTRY
ARE DOING. TWENTY NINETEEN TO
THE REGIONAL WATER BOARD AND
WE'RE WORKING HARD ON THAT AS WE
SPEAK.
AND PRODUCTION SIDE BUT THE
PROCESSING SIDE IS ALSO MAKING
SIGNIFICANT ADVANCEMENTS.
OTHERS A NEW PROGRAM THAT'S GAL
GRANTS ARE APPLICATIONS ARE DUE
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH THE
FOOD PRODUCTION INVESTMENT
PROGRAM WHICH AGAIN WAS FUNDED
BY THIS LEGISLATURE WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THE LAST TWO BUDGET
CYCLES.
AND THAT ALLOW THE DAIRY
PROCESSING PLANTS AND SHE'S
MANUFACTURERS TO MAKE SOME
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS.
ON THE PROCESSING SIDE AS WELL
FROM SUSTAINABILITY STANDPOINT.
SO ALL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING I'M --
AND WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO OUR
FIRST EVER CALIFORNIA JERRY
SUSTAINABILITY SUMMIT.
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE DOING LATER
THIS YEAR WE JUST ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY WEBSITE WENT LIVE TODAY --
IT'LL BE HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
WERE -- NOW
WORKING WITH THE ENTIRE DAIRY
INDUSTRY ON THIS PROJECT.
AND WE THINK IT'LL BE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO SHOWCASE
SOME OF THE WONDERFUL THINGS THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY DOING.
I'M GLAD AUDUBON BROUGHT UP THE
WORK WE'VE DONE ON TRI COLORED
BLACKBIRD SO WE'RE JUST GETTING
STARTED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
VERY.
GOOD PRESENTATION QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
I KNEW --
I'VE TAKEN A GREAT INTEREST IN
THIS DIET DAIRY DIE JUST OR THE
LAGOONS.
PARA METHANE REDUCTION --
THINKS I'M INTRIGUED BY YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I'M INTRIGUED
ABOUT THE WHOLE INDUSTRY AS A
WHOLE OF LIKE.
WHO'S DOING WHAT WHAT'S DOING
NEW.
AND SO EVERY NOW AND THEN I
THINK TO MYSELF SO --
THERE ARE.
AND YOU BY GNOME BUT FROM.
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE WORLD THAT
ARE DOING THIS VERY SUCCESSFULLY
ALREADY.
ARMY RECREATING THE WHEEL HERE
ARE IS ARE WE TAKING SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND EDUCATION THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM OTHER --
COUNTRIES INTO CONSIDERATION AND
DO WE HAVE TEST PLOTS THAT WE
CAN SEE SOME OF THAT ACTUALLY.
WORKING NOW --
YEAH THERE'S NO QUESTION WE'VE
LOOKED TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY --
OUR DAIRY INDUSTRY IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT EVEN THAN THE REST OF
THE NATION IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LOT OF LAGOONS.
AND THE GREEN DYE JESTERS ARE
NOT VERY COMMON IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY CERTAINLY NOT
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
OF AGAINST DON'T WORK VERY LONG
WISCONSIN IN THE WINTERTIME SO
THEY'VE THEY'VE TENDED TO STAY
WAY THEY TURNED ICE SKATING
RINKS THOUGH --
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT SO WE HAVE
SORT OF TAKEN THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
AND ADAPTED THEM TO CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE'RE SEEING A LOT MORE
OF THE COVERED THE GOON VARIETY
HERE THAN WE'VE SEEN ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE A FEW PLUG FLOW DIE
JESTERS OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA.
MORE BEING PROPOSED AND THERE
HAVE.
THEY ARE WIDELY USED IN GERMANY
AND THOSE HAVE NOT PERFORMED
PARTICULARLY WELL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT THEY CAN'T BE FURTHER
ADAPTED AND REMOVED.
WERE WERE TECHNOLOGY AGNOSTIC AS
AN INDUSTRY WE SUPPORT BOTH THE
AND PROGRAM AND THE DIGESTIVE
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY'RE BOTH
GOING TO BE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
NOT EVERY DAIRY CAN INSTALL AND
I JUST HER.
NOR GROUP WHO WOULD WE WANT
EVERY DAIRY TO PUT IT DIE JESTER
AND SO THE ALTERNATIVE PROGRAMS.
BECOME EQUALLY IMPORTANT BUT WE
ARE DOING A LOT OF RESEARCH.
ON THE CAMPSITE IN PARTICULAR
THE ALTERNATE MINORE MANAGEMENT
PRACTICE SIDE BECAUSE THAT IS
WHERE WE THINK THERE CAN BE A
LOT OF ADDITIONAL ADVANCEMENTS.
THE DIGEST HER STUFF'S PRETTY
SOLIDLY RESEARCH WE'VE GOT A
PROTOCOL WE CAN GENERATE CREDITS.
WE WANT TO GET THE APP PROGRAM
TO THE SAME LEVEL WHERE WE CAN
GENERATE.
GREENHOUSE GAS CREDIT REDUCTION
SO THAT FARMERS CAN GET SOME.
REVENUE FROM THOSE PROJECTS.
DIE JESTER FOR BIDE REVENUE
WHICH MAKES THEM VERY COST
EFFECTIVE.
THE AND PROGRAMS ARE ALSO ARE
PROJECTS ARE ALSO COST EFFECTIVE
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A REVENUE
STREAM GENERALLY ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM SO WE CAN DO THE RESEARCH.
DOCUMENT THE REDUCTIONS THAT
THEY CAN ACHIEVE GET PROTOCOLS
DEVELOPED LIKE WE HAVE FOR THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY.
OR THE RICE INDUSTRY HAS FOR I
THINK THE ONLY TWO IN
AGRICULTURE THAT HAVE PROTOCOLS.
THEN WE CAN GET CREDITS FOR
THOSE AND GENERATE REVENUE YOU.
SO WELL ENCOURAGING THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO WORK WITH US
TO GET THOSE BUTTON PLACE
QUICKLY COULD GO A LONG WAY.
AND REDUCED HIM TO SOME DEGREE
THAN.
SO WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING ACROSS
THE BOARD WE'D TRY NOT TO
DUPLICATE EFFORTS BUT WE DO TRY
TO LEARN FROM WHAT'S BEEN DONE
ELSEWHERE.
DO YOU HAVE TO BE PUBLISHED TO
GET TO DO SOME OF THIS WORK
[inaudible]
SOME.
AND THAT'S WHERE I'M HITTING A
WALL.
I'M SORRY BEING PUBLISHED THAT
YOU HAVE TO BE PUBLISHED BEFORE
ANY SOME OF THIS TECHNOLOGY CAN
BE USED IN CALIFORNIA.
HOMEBREW.
NO I DON'TKNOW THAT DID TO ITS
REALLY STOPPING TECHNOLOGIES
FROM BEING USED I THINK THE
RESEARCH TO BE CONSIDERED VALID
BY A OR B. AND OTHERS.
NEEDS TO BE PUBLISHED WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND STUDY
TO BE PUBLISHED.
IT WILL BE SHORTLY BUT FOR HOW
WE'RE GOING TO HELP YOU DO THAT
HOW CAN YOU.
MAKE THESE.
AMEND WE'RE SO WE'RE WASTING
TIME RIGHT LISTS HANDSOME
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT IS THERE A
WAY -- TO
GET.
YOUR INFORMATION YOU NEED.
PUBLISHED IN A TIMELY MANNER SO
THAT IT CAN USE YET WE'RE
WORKING.
AB ABOUT AS WELL AS AN INDUSTRY
CAN WORK WITH THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WE DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE
AND EVERYTHING NOT BY A LONG
SHOT BUT THEY'RE WORKING VERY
COOPERATIVELY WITH THIS INDUSTRY.
TO HELP US ACHIEVE THE
REDUCTIONS IT'S A GREAT WORKING.
YOU CAN ALWAYS BE BETTER --
BUT THEY'RE NOT STANDING IN THE
WAY THERE WE WE ARE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER TO GET THE INFORMATION
WE NEED. TO GET THROUGH THESE
VARIOUS PROTOCOLS AND AND GET
THE THINGS ESTABLISHED AS PAUL
CAN ATTEST TO THAT THE RIGHTS
COMMISSION THEY TAKE TIME --
HIM BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE DONE
CAREFULLY SO THAT THEY'RE
ACCURATE WHICH IS WHY WERE OUT
DOING THE RESEARCH TO VERIFY THE
REDUCTION.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW WHAT DIE
JESTERS WHAT THEY CAN ACHIEVE IN
TERMS OF REDUCTIONS IT'S WELL
DOCUMENTED HAS FOR YEARS WERE
NOT QUITE THERE BUT WE'LL BE
THERE IN A COUPLE OF YEARS IN
THE INDUSTRY IS PUTTING UP A LOT
OF THAT MONEY.
AND THE STATE'S MATCHING THAT
WITH US IN WORKING WITH US TO
GET THOSE REDUCTIONS.
ARE YOU KNOW HAVE PART OF THOSE
OF RECENT COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT
WE HAVE WITH THEIR BE IS THERE
GOING TO BE PUTTING SOME VERY
SOPHISTICATED TOWERS.
IN SOME OF THESE DAIRIES WERE
INSTALLING THESE ALTERNATE NOR
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES SO WE CAN
GAIN A COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE EMISSIONS PROFILE WE'RE NOT
JUST LOOK AT NOTHING.
WE WANT TO KNOW ARE THERE OTHER
TRADE OFFS OTHER BENEFITS WE
KNOW THE DIGEST YEARS PROVIDE
TREMENDOUS OTHER.
BENEFITS HOW REDUCING OTHER
POLLUTANTS ON THE DAIRY WE WANT
TO CHECK TO MAKE SURE THE SAME
THINGS OCCURRING WITH THESE
ALTERNATIVE PRACTICES.
AND DOCUMENTS AND THAT'S HOW WE
MAKE THE CASE.
FOR BETTER MAKE THE CASE FOR
MORE MONEY GOING FORWARD SO.
YOU HAVE GOT AYE MY MIND IS LIKE
TO GET STUFF DONE NOW.
AND IT'S FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THE
FARMERS IN THE DAIRY MEN ARE
COMING TO ME AND JUST SAYING --
WHERE PEOPLE ARE STANDING IN OUR
WAY -- I'M
JUST SAYING IS THAT IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
MOVE THINGS ALONG --
YOU KNOW I'M ONLY HERE FOR SO
LONG.
AND YOU KNOW IT.
THE WORLD'S CHANGING PLACE AND
HOW MUCH LONGER CAN WE WAIT SO
IT'S MY FRUSTRATION SO IT'S
GREATLY APPRECIATED I MEAN WHO
WE ARE WHERE WE ARE AS AN AND ST
WITH THESE EFFORTS SPEAK.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS STOOD UP
FOR US AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
THAT TO GET THE FUNDING.
AND I THINK WE'VE SHOWN THAT
IT'S GOOD BANG FOR THE BUCK AND
SO HOPEFULLY IT WILL CONTINUE IN
THE NEXT ADMINISTRATION AND WE
WILL ONLY HELP.
WITH THAT.
WITHOUT A DOUBT BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THAT
TRANSITION AND SO.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE EDUCATION PROCESS ALL OVER
AGAIN.
I LIKE FOR US MORE PUBLIC PART
OF PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
FOR ACTIVE.
AND I THINK --
HAVING THE PRIVATE SIZE THERE TO
HAVE THE MONEY TO HELP FUND AS
WELL AS MEAN AS MUCH AS WE'D
LIKE TO THINK STATE CAN DO IT
ALL.
WE CAN MEAN OF SO MANY THINGS TO
DO BUT IF WE CAN FORM THESE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS I
THINK THAT WE WOULD BE REALLY
BENEFICIAL.
AND RUSS AND FOR YOU AND THE GUY
JUST A PROGRAMS A GREAT EXAMPLE
ABOUT 30% ON AVERAGE OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE DIGEST HERS
COMES IN THE GRANT.
FROM THE REST IS COMING FROM THE
FARMERS OR OTHER EQUITY THAT WE
HAVE TO GO OUT FOR DEBT THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE ON FROM BANKS AND
OTHER SOURCES SO IT IS A NICE TO
LEVERAGE SITUATION.
YOU KNOW THAT TURNED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO BE
MORE LIKE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT WHEN IT'S ALL SAID
AND DONE.
IN THE DAIRY INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA SO THE OTHER THREE
QUARTERS OF THAT IS COMING FROM
INDUSTRY AND OTHER SOURCES SO.
THAT'S YOUR PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP AT WORK.
IS THERE A WAY --
TO TO MARKET.
THE HIGH SUSTAINABILITY YEAR
THAT.
EXTRA -- AT
THEY MAKE IT SEE THE BENEFIT OF
OF ALL OF THAT WORK IT IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION AND THE I KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA MILK ADVISORY
BOARD WHICH IS THE MARKETING ARM
OF THE CALIFORNIA DAIRY INDUSTRY
IS WORKING CLOSELY WITH US.
AND LOOKING AGES OF SORTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES HOW THE PLANET
SMART BARRIER PLANETS RIGHT MELT
YOU KNOW IS IS MY LITTLE EFFORT
TO BRAND THIS A LITTLE BIT --
THERE THE PROFESSIONALS THEY'RE
GONNA TAKE THAT TO THE NEXT
LEVEL BUT THERE IS A MARKET FOR
THERE'S NO QUESTION
AND PEOPLE ARE WHAT PRODUCTS
THAT ARE SUSTAINABLE.
AND I YOU KNOW WE THINK WE'VE
GOT A MUCH MORE SUSTAINABLE
DAIRY INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY'S PRETTY
GOOD AS WELL.
BUT WHEN YOU START TO LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA VERSUS THE REST OF
THE WORLD IT'S LIGHT YEARS IN
TERMS OF OUR OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT IN PARTICULAR FOR
EVERY GALLON ENOUGH PRODUCE.
RIGHT THOUGH THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
MY THOUGHT IS THAT IF THERE'S A
WAY TO MARKET IT'S IT'S SO.
MANY PEOPLE WILL BE WILLING TO
PAY FOR IT AND WOULD APPRECIATE
KNOWING THAT THAT THAT PRODUCT
HAS IT HAS A VALUE.
SO THAT'S GREAT UP MISTER
CHANDLER WANTED TO ASK YOU --
THIS YEAR.
OB WANTED THE ATTEMPTS I MADE
WAS TO DO A FARM BILL THAT WOULD
CREATE -- AN
OPPORTUNITY --
TO TO LOOK AT TAX CREDITS FOR
SMALL AND MEDIUM Y. ACTUALLY WAS
FOR ALL FOR ALL FARMING BUT THE
INNER TO THE BENEFIT OF SMALL
AND MEDIUM.
FARMS IF THERE IF IT FOR IT.
DOES IT DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO
TRY TO TO PUT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT TOGETHER THAT CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FARMS TO BE
ABLE TO USE THE KIND OF OF
EFFICIENCIES THAT YOU'D YOU
DESCRIBED IT IT SOUNDS TO ME
LIKE YOU'RE.
YOU'RE DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT
AND WHAT REALLY HELPED IN THE
TRACTOR AREA WAS HAVING THOSE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
AIR BOARD AND THE MORE THAT WE
CAN [inaudible]
CREATE THOSE.
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK THE BETTER.
THE MORE THAT WE CAN SAY THAT
MIGHT YOU KNOW MIGHT MY INTEREST
IS MAKING SURE THAT AGRICULTURE
IS SUSTAINABLE AND THAT IT IT IS.
HOT [inaudible]
IT IS.
ABLE TO CONTINUE IN THE STATE
AND SO I'M AND A BIG CONCERN IS
THE LOS OF SMALL FARMS.
COM SOME JUST WONDERING IF IF
I'LL BE BACK AGAIN AND I'LL BE
I'LL HAVE A IT WOULD I PUT
EVERYTHING IN IT BUT THE KITCHEN
SINK IN.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU DO THAT THE
FIRST TIME PEOPLE THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMETHING THEY DON'T LIKE BUT
BUT I THINK THERE'S SOME REAL.
I'M INTEREST IN THE LEGISLATURE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT PERFORMING IN SO THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND.
ARE ONE POTENTIAL SOURCE WE USE
TO HAVE THE WILLIAMS WILLIAMSON
ACT IS ANOTHER --
WE'RE DOING SOME GREAT LAND
CONSERVATION --
WORK AS WELL BUT IT.
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THE MORE
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX THAT THERE
ARE THAT THAT IT MAY BE HELPFUL
AND I'M WONDERING WHAT YOU
THOUGHT YOU THOUGHT YOU THINK
THINK ABOUT THAT INCENTIVE SIR.
TAX CREDITS Y. I THINK --
THE INCENTIVES OF AN ENORMOUSLY
POWERFUL IN THAT YOU KNOW.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCING SATAN ON
A GIVEN THIS ROOM WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT --
BUT WE'RE ALSO PROBABLY THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY AWARE STATE AND
THERE'S A COST TO THAT.
AND AND YOU'RE RIGHT WHEN YOUR
CONCERN IS IS --
THAT THE SMALL MEDIUM SIZED
FARMS -- I
HAVE A TOUGHER TIME WITH THAT
COST BECAUSE THEY ARE UNABLE TO
SPREAD IT OUT AND THESE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN A
VERY HELPFUL --
AND THAT THE TWO THAT I TALKED
ABOUT THE TWO STATE PROGRAMS --
UP I'VE I'VE WORKED WITH HAVE
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS
AND AS A FARMER MY MY MAIN JOB
IS FARMING IT'S NOT APPLYING FOR
PROGRAMS --
WHEN I APPLY FOR FEDERAL PROGRAM
THEY CAN BE A VERY DIFFICULT
PROCESS AND I SPEND A LOT OF
TIME HAVING TO FILL OUT A LOT OF
FORUMS AND I HAVE A LOT OF --
FOLLOW UPS AND AND WHAT NOT KNOW
WHAT WITH THE POWER OF THE STATE
PROGRAMS --
THAT I'VE HAD EXPERIENCE WITH
AND WHY I THINK THEY'VE BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL IS THEIR VERY USER
FRIENDLY --
CDFA MANAGES --
THE SWEET PROGRAM AND THAT
THEY'RE VERY EASY TO WORK WITH
THEIR VERY STRAIGHT FOR THEY
HAVE VERY TOUGH --
STANDARDS THEY WANT YOU TO MEET
BUT THEY HELP YOU UNDERSTAND --
HOW YOU CAN WORK TO MEET THOSE
SO I IT'S IT'S VERY AGGRESSIVE
IN TRYING TO GET GROWERS ENGAGED
IN THAT I THINK THAT'S HELPFUL --
WITH THE TRACTOR REPLACEMENT --
THERE AGAIN IT IS VERY USER
FRIENDLY IT'S FOR THE GROWERS
IT'S VERY SIMPLE MATTER OF GOING
THROUGH THE APPLICATION PROCESS
AND THERE'S HELP READILY
AVAILABLE.
AND I THINK THAT --
ALONG WITH THE DRIVE --
STATEWIDE HAS A BEEN A LARGE
PART WHY THOSE PROGRAMS AND HAVE
BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL AND WHY FOR
FOR MY FARM I FIND THEM --
VERY HELPFUL JUST BECAUSE AS I'M
LOOKING AT NEW STANDARDS OR OR
NEW REGULATIONS ORA EVEN BEFORE
THEY HAPPEN WILL --
THEY HELPED ME BE AHEAD OF THE
CURVE OR MEET THE NEW STANDARDS
WITHOUT HAVING TO MOVE BASICALLY
MORTGAGE THE FAR RIGHT.
RIGHT THAT'S GREAT APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH --
IN THEN ALSO ON THE I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO ACTUALLY AND I WAS DOING A
SITES RESERVOIR TOUR AND I ENDED
UP OUT THERE --
JUST AROUND THE TIME AT THE END
OF THE SEASON --
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THERE
IT WAS IT WAS FANTASTIC.
TO I'VE ACTUALLY AVERAGE JUST.
TALKING TO CECILIA ABOUT IT IS --
TO ACTUALLY GO.
PASSED A FARM WHERE --
BIRDS HAVE BEEN --
FEEDING I GUESS IS THE BEST WAY
TO SAY IT FOR AND TO SEE THEM
NOTHING MORE POWERFUL. TO SEE
NATURE CAN AT ITS BEST DOING
WHAT IT DOES AND THEN TO FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE TOTALLY
INCONSEQUENTIAL SHINTO I MEAN IT
REALLY WAS PHENOMENAL AND SO.
I BECOME A REAL A REAL FAN OF OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING --
TO CREATE HABITAT AND TO PROVIDE
NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
SHOREBIRDS AND IS WHEN YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE THE WATER
LEAVING THE RICE FIELDS AND
MOVING MOVING ON DOES ANY OF
THAT WATER GET.
FURTHER SOUTH OF OF THE OF THE
RICE FIELDS --
ME IN AND I THE REASON I ASK
THAT IS IS THE SIGNIFICANT AREA
WHERE THERE IS.
UP WETLANDS THAT HAS BEEN
CREATED WITH FARMLAND AND WITH --
SOME CONSERVATION GROUPS IS AND
IS IN MISTER GRAY'S --
DISTRICT WHICH IS ROB RIGHT
THERE OFF OF THE NINETY NINE
FREEWAY.
ACTUALLY IT'S THAT IT'S A FIVE
FREE WEIGHT OVER TO THE NINE
NINE FREEWAY AND THAT THAT --
PROPERTY IS JUST INCREDIBLE AND
ITS THOUSANDS OF ACRES AND A BIG
CHALLENGES HAVING.
IT BE PARTICULARLY IN THAT AREA
IT'S HAVING ENOUGH WATER
AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO KEEP THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF WATER IN THE
DIFFERENT FIELDS FOR THE
DIFFERENT SPECIES AND SO.
THE MORE THAT WE CAN WORK OUT
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE
ABLE. TO TO TO USE THE WATER
THAT WE HAVE AS MANY TIMES AS
POSSIBLE FOR AS MANY USES.
AS POSSIBLE IN IT WHICH IS I
THINK TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT AND
AND IF YEAR IF THERE IS RESEARCH
THAT'S BEING DONE IN TERMS OF
THE KINDS OF OF OF PLANT
MATERIALS.
THAT ARE THAT MIGHT BE GOOD.
TO ALSO TAKE --
FURTHER SOUTH NEAR GROWING RICE
AND MAYBE IT'S SEEDING SOME RICE
IN THIS PARTICULAR REGION JUST
SO THAT THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT --
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HERB FOR BIRDS
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE UP AND DOWN --
THAT.
CALIFORNIA I THINK THE MORE
INFORMATION WE HAVE THE MORE
DATA WE HAVE THE MORE SCIENCE WE
USE I THINK.
WOULD BE TREMENDOUSLY THREAT
TRYING TO MEND THE SAY IMPORTANT
I'VE I'VE ALSO BEEN OUT.
BOB TO THOSE WETLANDS AND IT'S
IT'S INCREDIBLE THAT VARIETY OF
BIRDS THAT YOU SEE AND THAT
THOSE ARE DEBT CLUBS THAT ARE
KEEPING THAT THAT GOING SO SURE
VERY IMPORTANT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVEA
QUESTION THERE IN I DON'T KNOW
IF MR GRAY HAS A QUESTION FOR
YOU EITHER BUT I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT DOT.
THAT I I WAS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPRESSED WITH --
THE AMOUNT OF OF WILDLIFE THAT'S
THAT IS.
THAT LIVES IN THAT AREA.
RIGHT AFTER THE RACE --
HARVEST IS DONE IN THE FACT THAT
THERE IS.
PEPPER PRODUCE STILL IN THE
FIELD I THINK IS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT AND HOW DO WE MARKET
THAT. TO THE PUBLIC.
NOT THAT HAS NO CLUE THAT THESE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE GOING ON I
THINK WE NEED TO TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL SHARE WHICH
ARE GREAT.
THANK YOU --
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
NICE COMMENTS ABOUT MY DISTRICT
WERE VERY PROUD OF IT --
IT IT IS UNDER APPRECIATED LET
ME JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE TRAVEL UP AND DOWN
THAT I'VE I FIVE FREEWAY AND
HAVE NO CLUE THAT THAT WETLANDS
IS THERE I MEAN I THINK THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY.
DOES WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND
CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
TESTIMONY IT'S NICE.
TO BE HERE IN THE HALLS.
OF THE CAPITOL ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF
AGRICULTURE --
IT'S TOO OFTEN THAT --
WERE CRITICIZED AND FRANKLY --
I DON'T THINK AGRICULTURE SPEAKS
UP.
A IN ITS OWN DEFENSE ENOUGH HERE
EARLIER THIS YEAR I WROTE AN OP
ED WHEN MY LOCAL PAPERS.
TELL NEVER APOLOGIZE FOR BEING A
FARMER AND IT CAME FROM A
MEETING I HAD WITH A CERTAIN.
U. S. KING ARE CANDID FOR U. S.
SENATE --
WITH A BUNCH OF FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS ARE WERE TALKING
BUT I CULTURE IN THE DIFFERENT
OPERATIONS IN MY DISTRICT AND
AND EVERY SINGLE CONSTITUENT AT
THIS PARTICULAR MEETING
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES AS A SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS.
YOUR SOME OF THEM ARE SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS SUMMER REALLY BIG
FAMILY FARMERS --
BUT THEIR FAMILY FARMERS --
BUT AT THE END OF ALL THAT I GOT
THE UP TO SPEAK I SAID YOU KNOW
ONE OF THINGS A TIRED OF IS THAT.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT.
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR OUR
INDUSTRY.
ON THE IN THOSE TERMS BECAUSE IT
FOR BIG GAG OR EVIL.
AND AS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GOTTA
SILICON VALLEY DO THE GOOGLE
DESCRIBES ITSELF AS A SMALL
FAMILY TECH.
FOR DO THEY HAVE TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THEIR SUCCESSES YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T AND SAID SO GRANT
THAT WISH THAT'S PAUL GESTURES
AND THAT'S AGAIN.
THANK YOU MANAGER FOR LONG
OVERDUE PUT AND HE TO CELEBRATE
A LOT OF THE GOOD WORK THAT GOES
ON EVERYDAY.
ACROSS THE STATE NOT JUST IN MY
DISTRICT WERE SHOULD PROUD OF
SOME OF THE THINGS WE'VE DONE IN
MY PART OF THE WORLD IS WHAT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
SO THAT BRINGS US --
TO THE NEXT PANEL WHICH IS ABOUT
WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS AND SO I'D
LIKE TO INVITE STEPHANIE LARSON.
PHD DIRECTOR OF THE U. S.
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION CINEMA
COUNTY --
CINEMA COUNTY LIVESTOCK AND
RANGE MANAGEMENT ADVISER THAT'S
A LONG [inaudible]
TITLE.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DIVISION OF AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES WELCOME WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY COME BEFORE YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YES I AM US STEPHANIE LARSON.
AND MY RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
PROGRAM TOM --
DOCUMENTS AND INTEGRATES
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES PROVIDED BY
RANGELANDS HIGHLIGHTING THE
BENEFITS OF USING GRAZING
ANIMALS AS TOOLS TO MANAGE SHE'S
WORKING LANDSCAPES.
I'M A CERT RANGE LAND MANAGER.
I WORK WITH LAND MANAGERS
HELPING THEM TO MAKE SOUND
ECOLOGICAL DECISIONS TO MANAGE
WORKING LANDSCAPES FOR THE
BENEFITS OF ALL USERS.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY IS AN EXPERT
WITHIN MY FIELD AND AS A PRIVATE
INDIVIDUAL.
I'M NOT AS AN OFFICIAL
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK THE PANEL A
MEMBERS AHEAD OF ME AND THEY'VE
KIND OF SET THE STAGE IN A SENSE --
FOR A DIALOGUE THAT I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN HAVE IN THIS IN THIS
SESSION AND TALKING ABOUT
WORKING LANDSCAPES AND IS THAT
IT'S A TERM THAT'S THAT WE USE.
AND IT'S ALL FOR MORE RELEVANT
IN A HOW DO WE KEEP OUR
LANDSCAPES WORKING WHEN I THINK
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
LANDSCAPES THE INCLUDE FARMLAND.
RANCHES RANGELANDS FOREST
WETLANDS MINES WATER BODIES AND
OTHER NATURAL RESOURCE LANCE FOR
BOTH PRIVATE AND PUBLIC.
THEY BENEFIT US FROM CLEAN WATER
AND NUTRITIOUS FOOD TO CLIMATE
STABILITY AND OUTDOOR RECREATION
AND THE PROVIDES ESSENTIAL
BENEFITS FOR OUR ECONOMY OUR
HEALTH IN THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE CROSSED ALL
ASPECTS OF AGRICULTURE THIS
AFTERNOON.
AND HE'S ECOSYSTEM SERVICES ARE
OFTEN TAKEN FOR GRANTED AND I
THINK WHAT WE WE FIND IS THAT
AGRICULTURE CAN BE VERY SILO.
AND THEY ARE THEY'RE VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT THEY
PROVIDE AND THEY'RE VERY PROUD
AS YOU HEARD JUST BEFORE ME ON
THAT ON THE SUCCESS STORIES THAT
THEY HAVE.
BUT I THINK THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
HEAR THESE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES I
THINK WHEN THEY THINK ABOUT
AGRICULTURE THEY THINK ABOUT
FOOD.
THEY THINK ABOUT THE THE WATER
THAT WE'RE USING TO GROW THAT
FOOD.
AND THEY'RE QUESTIONING HOW
WE'RE GROWING THAT FOOD IS IT IS
IT SUSTAINABLE IS THAT ORGANIC
IS A SMALL SCALE IS AT LARGE
SCALE.
THEY DON'T THINK ABOUT THAT THE
CROSS SECTION OF ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES THAT THESE WORKING A
LANDSCAPES PROVIDE.
AND THERE ARE WILL BECAUSE ARE
TAKEN FOR GRANTED THERE'S A
MARKET FIRE THAT HITS
PARTICULARLY HARD IN THE RURAL
AREAS.
AND SO A STRONGER FRAMEWORK FOR
MAPPING VALUE IN INVESTING
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES CAN ENSURE
THOSE WHO MANAGE THESE
CALIFORNIA WORKING LANDS OR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS WILL
BENEFIT FROM STEWARDING THEM.
SO I WANT TO TALK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT SOME GOING FORWARD AND HOW
WE CAN.
REALLY A SASS AND AND CHAMPION
WHAT AGRICULTURE IS DOING RIGHT.
AND I THINK WHEN WE THINK ABOUT.
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES AND AGAIN
UNFORTUNATE THEIR SENSE TO BE A
LOT OF JARGON WORDS WITH
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES BUT IT'S THE
WAY THAT NATURE PROVIDES FOR THE
WELL BEING OF PEOPLE.
INCLUDES A BIOLOGICAL NECESSITY
SO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT CLEAN
WATER NUTRITIOUS FOOD IN A
LIVABLE CLIMATE AS WELL AS
INDIRECT ECONOMIC BENEFITS SUCH
AS JOB IN REVENUE.
CREATED ALONG THE THE FOOD VALUE
CHAINS.
MORE BROADLY TO ENCOMPASS
INTANGIBLE GOODS AND CONTRIBUTE
TO A HUMAN WELL BEING SUCH AS
RECREATION ASCETIC INSPIRATION A
CULTURAL CONNECTION.
WHAT THEY HAVE IN COMMON IS THAT
THEY DEPEND ON NATURAL CAPITAL
OR IN OTHER WORDS GENERATED OF
CAPITAL?
UP ABILITIES OF NATURAL SYSTEMS
OR WORKING LANCE SO WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE MILLENNIAL.
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES IT THERE'S A
LOT OF WORDS BUT WHEN YOU BOIL
IT DOWN THERE'S LIKE
PROVISIONING OR WATER.
SO THE PROVISIONING SERVICES SO
WHAT DO THESE AGRICULTURAL LANDS
PROVIDE.
AND SO WHAT I'M BUT GOING
FORWARD WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS
START DOCUMENTING THOSE SUCCESS
STORIES AND LOOKING AT CASE
STUDIES AND ASKING OURSELVES YOU
KNOW WHERE MIGHT WE FIND SOME
WAYS TO HIGHLIGHT THESE.
AND TO INCENTIVIZE THESE FOR OUR
FOLKS THAT ARE MANAGING THOSE
LANDS SOME YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THAT THIS IS THE STORY OF
NEW YORK CITY.
WHERE THEY HAD TO TO LOOK AT
APPLY A WATER SOURCE TO ALL THE
PEOPLE?
AND SO THEY LOOKED AT NINETEEN
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES BETWEEN AT
THE CATSKILLS IN THE DELAWARE
WATERSHEDS IN UPPER STATE NEW
YORK [inaudible]
AND THEY INTO AND THEY CREATED
ONE OF THE LARGEST ENGINEERED
WATER SYSTEMS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
SO THEY WORKED WITH THE PRIVATE
LAND OWNERS. TO HELP THEM
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR THIS LAND THIS WATER
TO COME THROUGH THE LAND.
BOTH URBAN AND RURAL RESIDENTS
BENEFITTED FROM AN AGREEMENT
THAT INCLUDES LAND ACQUISITION.
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS AND
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES FOR FARM.
A RIGHT PERRY NEARS AND FORESTS
SO TOOK ALL OF THOSE THINGS SO
IT'S FROM THE THE FOR WHERE THE
WATER FALLS. TO THE END USERS.
SO GOING FORWARD ONE
RECOMMENDATION COULD BE --
TO CREATE AND EXPAND MARKETS FOR
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES AND MIGHT ONE
OPTION MIGHT BE IN THESE WERE
INCLUDED IN YOUR PACKETS.
USE ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS OR SIMILAR
MECHANISMS TO CREATE LOCAL OR
REGIONAL MARKETS FOR NATURAL
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO ITS INCORPORATING THE COST OF
CONSERVING NATURAL CAPITAL SUCH
AS AN UPPER WATERSHED FOREST OR
RIGHT PAIRING CORRIDORS
INCENTIVIZING THAT FOR
LANDOWNERS TO IMPROVE THE FORCE
MANAGEMENT THE RIGHT PAYING
CORRIDORS.
AND THEN THE WATER FEES ARE PAID
BY THE END USERS WHO BENEFIT
FROM THAT CAPITAL SO HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO THE
PUBLIC TO SAY.
YOUR BENEFITING FROM THE WATER
THAT FALLS ON THESE AGRICULTURE
LANDS AND FROM THAT STANDPOINT
WE'RE GOING TO CHARGE YOU EXTOL
THERE'S YOU KNOW. FOR THE USE OF
THAT WATER.
SO THAT MIGHT BE A WAY TO AT
LEAST START TO MAKE THAT THAT
CONNECTION THAT PEOPLE --
DON'T REALLY HAVE THE PUBLIC
MISSES THE FACT THAT AGRICULTURE
LANDS ARE PROVIDING THE WATER.
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT THE
VALUE OF OF AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS --
I THINK ONE INTERESTING
STATISTIC IS THAT --
UNIVERSE TO CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL ISSUES CENTER FOUND
THAT A COMBINED MULTIPLIER
EFFECT OF TWO POINT.
SEVEN IN IT FOR EVERY DOLLAR
FARM GATE THERE WAS ANOTHER
DOLLAR AND TWENTY SEVEN CENTS
ADDED TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
SO THAT AGRICULTURE PRODUCTION
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE ACT
OF THE ECONOMY IN THAT DOLLAR
COMES YOU ADDED JOBS AND AND
PRODUCTS AND SALES SO IT'S
HIGHLIGHTING THAT.
SO WHAT WE HEARD ABOUT TODAY
ABOUT ANOTHER OPTION MIGHT BE TO
EXPAND EXISTING MARKETS FOR FARM
LAND AND RANGE LAND CONSERVATION
AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT --
CERTAIN PROBLEMS PROGRAMS SUCH
AS SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE LANDS
CONSERVATION PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S PROVIDING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES.
BY CONSERVATION EASEMENTS BUT
WHAT ABOUT IF WE WERE TO NOT
MORE ALSO ALSO PAY FOR ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES SO WE HAVE THESE LANDS
AND WHERE WERE.
WERE A SETTING THEM ASIDE.
FOR IN PERPETUITY SO THAT THEY
CAN'T BE DEVELOPED.
WHAT IS HAPPENED IS THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN?
FIRST SECOND AND NOW THIRD AND
FOURTH GENERATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THOSE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS AND THEY
THE FOURTH GENERATIONS ARE
STRUGGLING ON HOW HOW DO THEY
MAKE MONEY OFF THOSE LANDS.
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE MAKE?
KEEP THOSE LANDS ACTIVE AND AND
SO WHAT I'VE DONE IS WE DID SOME
RESEARCH AND WE ASSESSED IN THIS
WAS IN MARIN AND SONOMA COUNTY
ON TWO VERY ESTABLISHED LAND
TRUST AND ASK THE QUESTION ABOUT.
WOULD YOU TAKE ONGOING PAYMENTS
OR WHERE YOU ARE USE SOLID
WITHOUT MOM SOME WELL
SURPRISINGLY THE FOLKS THAT TOOK
THE LUMP SUM OF THE ORIGINAL
CONSERVATION EASEMENT LIKE
GRANDPA HE THOUGHT THAT WAS A
GREAT --
DEAL BUT GRAND SON OR DAUGHTER
COMING ON THIRD YOU KNOW TH
GENERATION IS LOOKING AT HOW DO
I KEEP THIS LAND GOING I DON'T
HAVE ANY MONEY ALL I CAN SELL IS
A COUPLE OF COWS --
SO HOW DO WE INCENTIVIZE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS WHAT IF
THESE CONSERVATION EASEMENT
PAYMENTS WORD WERE DONE OVER
TIME.
GIVING FOLKS THE OPTION TO LOOK
AT INVESTING THAT MONEY AND THEN
PAYMENTS OVER TIME THAT IS MORE
OF A SUCCESSION PLANNING FOR
FARMING SO THAT KEEPS THEM GOING.
SO THAT'S THE IDEA THAT.
SON GRANDSON DAUGHTER
GRANDDAUGHTER ALL KNOW THAT THEY
ARE GUARANTEED PAYMENTS FOR A
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE INCENTIVIZING
THAT AND THEN LOOKING AT OKAY
YOU'VE SOLDIER DEVELOPMENT
RIGHTS.
WHAT IF WE PAGE YOU TO SEQUESTER
CARBON WHAT IF WE INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF CARBON FARMING THAT
YOU DID WHAT YOU PUT COMPOST ON
IT FOR THE MOVE TO A MORE?
PERENNIAL SYSTEM AT IN WOODY
VEGETATION UP.
PAIN FOR POLLINATION AYE INC
INCREASE SEEN THAT CARBON WHAT
ABOUT IF YOU HAD WATER.
ATTENTION WHAT IF YOU WERE
HOLDING WATER IN CAPTURING WATER
WHAT IF YOU PAID FOR THAT LIKE
SOME OF THAT --
PROGRAMS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER SO IS THIS IDEA THAT
MAYBE OF SOLDIER DEVELOPMENT
RIGHTS IN PERPETUITY BUT WHAT
ABOUT ONGOING PAYMENTS OF OF
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES.
SO THAT COULD BE ANOTHER.
ANOTHER IDEA --
I THINK IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
FROM AN EDUCATIONAL STANDPOINT
AND AND THIS IS WHAT WE'VE DONE
KIND OF IT WAS A FUN PROJECT BUT
IT REALLY IS AND PACTUAL.
IS WHERE. ONE ANOTHER ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES IS CULTURAL ITS
RECREATIONAL AND SOUL COLLIGAN I
LOOKED AT THE REGIONAL PARKS THE
THE PARKS LETTER GRACED.
IN -- IN THE
BAY AREA AND IN IN A NORTHERN
SONOMA COUNTY.
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT PEOPLE
WERE WANDERING AS OUR HIKING
AROUND WHY OTHER COWS OUT THERE.
AND SO OR THERE WAS INCIDENTS
WHERE COWS AND DOGS DIDN'T MIX
VERY WELL AND PEOPLE ARE HIKING
SO WE TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATE FOLKS.
AND SAY THIS IS WHY WE HAVE CAL.
IT'S TO REDUCE FIRE FUEL IS TO
IMPROVE OUR HABITAT IT'S FOR
BIODIVERSITY AND WE PUT UP SIGNS
WE MADE YOU KNOW EDUCATIONAL
PACKETS AND SO FOLKS ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE IN SAYING Y.
UNDERSTAND WHY THERE ARE ANIMALS
GRAZING OUT HERE.
AND WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS
EXPANDING THAT THOSE PROJECTS IN
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES FOR AREAS
THAT ARE.
THAT HAVE BEEN OR COULD BE
IMPACTED BY THE RECENT FIRES
THAT WE'VE HAD AND SO IT'S THIS
IDEA OF OF GENERATING MAPPING TO
SHOW THAT AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
GRACED OR AREAS THAT HAD
AGRICULTURE.
DIDN'T BURN ES SEVERELY OR THE
FIRE STOPPED THERE AND SO IT'S
TAKING THAT OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ST WE NEED TO
MANAGE THESE WORKING LANDSCAPES
WHETHER IT'S MANAGING OUR TIMBER
WHETHER IT'S GRAZING --
AND I'M ALSO STARTING.
BACK OF PRESCRIBED BURNING
ASSOCIATIONS AND TALKING TO
COLLEAGUES THAT THEY DID THIS
FIFTY YEARS AGO AND SO IT'S NOT
LIKE REINVENTING THE WHEEL IS
JUST MAKING THE WILL TURN AGAIN.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS.
STARTING THE PROCESS OF WORKING
WITH LANDOWNERS TO SAY HOW DO WE
MANAGE VEGETATION WITH ALL THE
TOOLS WHAT IF WE USE GRAZING BUT
IF WE USE PRESCRIBED FIRE AND SO
WHAT WE'RE STARTING TO DO IS
WORK WITH CAL FIRE AND AIR
DISTRICTS.
AND AND LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
DECIDE WHAT WHERE'S THE BEST WAY
AND THAT THE MARKETS ECONOMIC
WAY TO MANAGE THESE.
THESE OF WORKING LANDSCAPES TO
REDUCE FIRE --
IMPACTS [inaudible]
NOW WHAT.
PROBABLY GOING FORWARD WE'RE
GOING TO NEED HELP WITH IS.
IS THE AIRPORTS.
AND A PENNY WHERE YOU'RE LOCATED
OUT SOMETIMES THE REALLY
AGREEABLE AND SOMETIMES BAY AREA
THEY'RE NOT --
AS OPEN TO BERNIE.
SO I THINK.
THE FIRES ARE OUR A A TRAVESTY
BUT THERE IS ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO START ASKING THE
PUBLIC TO WORK WITH US ON
MANAGING THESE WORKING
LANDSCAPES SO THAT'S THAT'S AN
EXCITING WAY THAT WE'RE GOING
FORWARD.
SO WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
DOCUMENTING --
PILOT PROJECTS AND LOOKING AT
SUCCESS STORIES THAT HAVE
HAPPENED AND PERHAPS TAKING THE
SANTA ANA WATERSHED AREA AND AND
LOOKING OUT THE IMPACTS FROM THE
TOP OF THE WATERSHED TO THE
USERS AND LA AND JUST.
TRYING TO EDUCATE THE ARM
ALTHOUGH.
A WHOLE CONTINUUM OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF WORKING LANDSCAPES
LOOKING AT THE KING'S RIVER
BASIN IN AND WHAT I'M WORKING
WITH FARMERS THERE WHO ARE FOR
OUR OF DOING FLOOD MITIGATION.
AND THEY HAVE THEIR DOING THAT
IN PERPETUITY SO IT'S THIS WHOLE
IDEA OF A CAVE THEY'RE ALREADY
GETTING PAYMENTS TO DO THAT.
SO WHAT IF SOME ADDITIONAL OR
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS OR
ADDITIONAL STACKING OF ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES THAT COULD BE PROVIDED
IN COULD BE ALSO PROVIDE MONEY
FOR THAT.
I THINK THE KEY WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE THESE
WORKING LANDSCAPES IS THAT THE
ECONOMICS OF THEM --
THE SOCIAL ASPECT OF IT AND
ECOLOGICAL PEACE OF IT BUT IF
YOU'RE OWNING LAND AND YOU
WANTING TO KEEP IT FOR
GENERATION AND GENERATION YOU
HAVE TO MAKE MONEY AT IT SO WE
HAVE TO INCENTIVIZE AS OPPOSED.
TO REGULATE THESE LANDOWNERS AND
THESE WORKING LANDSCAPES TO KEEP
THEM ACTIVE AND KEEP THEM
WORKING [inaudible]
SO -- I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
LOOK AT THAT WE HAVE.
ALL THE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX AND
THAT FROM A SCIENCE STANDPOINT
WERE ALSO LOOKING AT IDEAS OF
INCREASING --
MARKETS FOR FOR CARBON MARKETS
FOR HABITAT CONSERVATION AND SO
LOOKING AT THOSE BENEFITS AND
AND ENCOURAGING LANDOWNERS TO
THINK ABOUT HOW DO WE ADD VALUE
TO OUR WORKING LANDS PERHAPS TWO
AGRITOURISM AND MAYBE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME INCENTIVES. TO TO
LOOK AT INCREASING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR AGRITOURISM AND REDUCING
LIABILITY ISSUES THAT IMPACT THE
BILL THE ABILITY TO BRING PEOPLE
ONTO YOUR PROPERTY.
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING HAPPENS ON
THE PROPERTY THEN THE THE
LANDOWNERS LIABLE AND SO THERE'S
THERE'S OTHER EXAMPLES OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE BRINGING IN TO SHOW TO SAY.
HERE'S WHAT THEY DO IN OREGON
THERE'S A REDUCE LIABILITY IT'S
IT HELPS PEOPLE TO COME ON IN
AND ADD VALUE TO THEIR PROPERTY.
AND SO.
ANOTHER ISSUE IS THAT WE WANT TO
LOOK AT INCREASING MAPPING AND
WHAT THE MAPPING SKILLS THAT WE
CAN START TO DOCUMENT AND
PRIORITIZE.
WHERE'S THE BIGGEST --
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO SOME I IT
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME OF THESE
WORKING LAND PRACTICES AND HOW
DO WE DOCUMENT THE THE BIGGEST --
RETURN ON THE INVESTMENT OF SOME
OF THESE PROJECTS SO START TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY AND TAKE ALL
OF THESE GREAT STORIES THAT YOU
HEARD EARLIER.
AND LOOK OUT.
DO WE HAVE THE SCIENCE TO BACK
IT WHAT ADDITIONAL RESEARCH DO
WE NEED TO DO AND HOW DO WE TELL
THAT STORY.
SO I'M JUST GIVING YOU AN
OVERVIEW AND WHAT WHAT --
WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING WORKING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA FORWARD --
AND THAT THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC.
SUMMIT IS THE ECOSYSTEM SERVICE
WORKING LANDSCAPES IS BRINGING
THIS CONCEPT FORWARD IN NOVEMBER.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO PRESENT
THIS SO CREATED THIS ECOSYSTEM
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA WORKING
LANDSCAPES PAPER.
THAT -- WAS
SENT.
AND IT KIND OF JUST COVERS WHAT
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES ARE IN SOME
OF THOSE POTENTIAL THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
THERE AND SO WE BOIL DOWN TO
THIS.
AS ONE PAGER MAKES IT EASIER TO
READ SO WITHOUT I WOULD I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO HAVE A DIALOGUE OR
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
MR LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MISS LARSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION YOU
REALLY TOUCHED ON A LOT OF
ISSUESTHAT.
YOU HAVE BEEN FROM THE NORTH BAY
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH BUT ARE
ALSO CERTAINLY STATEWIDE IN IN
THEIR APPLICATION.
CERTAIN WHAT ONE OF THE
INSTANCES FOR EXAMPLE IS THAT IN
THE NORTH BAY WE WERE REALLY
PIONEERS IN ORGANIC MILK STRAUSS
BEING THE FIRST IN THE STATE TO
GO ORGANIC AND THEN.
EVERYONE FIGURED OUT THIS WAS A
WAY TO MAKE MONEY AND TO MAKE IT
AS A SMALL DAIRY --
AND BE PROFITABLE AND EVERYONE
FIGURED THAT OUT AND THERE'S A
GLUT OF ORGANIC MILK AND THAT'S
PUTTING A LOT OF PRESSURE ON OUR
DAIRIES --
IN IN CERTAINLY WE'VE SEEN THE
POSITIVE OUTCOMES OF OF HAVING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE IT
WHICH IS AMAZING SHE'S.
AND AND OF COURSE TOURISM THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND WE'VE
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO TELL A VERY
POSITIVE STORY FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS WE HEARD FROM ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES --
TO HILLS AGRICULTURE IS UNDER
APPRECIATED.
AND YOU I COME FROM A COUNTY
WHERE WE ACTUALLY PASSED A SALES
TAX.
THAT GOES TO FUND EASEMENTS TO
KEEP.
DE OUR LAND AS WORKING
AGRICULTURE SO WE AS RESIDENTS
DECIDED TO TAX OURSELVES TO KEEP
THE AGRICULTURAL HERITAGE.
OF THE NORTH BAY AND IT'S A
REALLY AMAZING STORY TO TELL
IT'S ONE WHERE YOU KNOW
AGRICULTURE IS NOT UNDER
APPRECIATED AT ALL AND YOU THINK
LIKE -
EVERYONE OUT ON THE COAST
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT BACK AND
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
INCLUDING PAIN OUT OF HER OWN
POCKET TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T LOSE.
THAT LOCAL AGRICULTURE AND DIE
IN A REAL SENSE THAT FARMING IS
COOL.
I THAT I FEEL WHENEVER ON
ANYWHERE IN CINEMA OFF THE WELL
NO ONE AND CERTAINLY OFF OF THAT
ONE ONE IN MARIN.
AS WELL --
AND IT'S IT'S JUST A VERY
POSITIVE PERSON VERY GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THE WORKING LEADERSHIP
THAT YOU DO I'M VERY EXCITED FOR
THE COMIC SUMMIT BEAN IN CINEMA
THIS YEAR THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
SHOW THAT OFF.
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S --
CLIMATE CHANGE SUMMIT WE WERE
ALSO GOING TO BE ABLE TO I TAKE
PEOPLE TO WORKING LANCE.
SURE SURE WITH A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE HEALTHY SOILS
INITIATIVE THAT WE HAVE EVEN
TEACH THEM ABOUT OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND HOW THAT
IMPACTS OUR OUR FARMING IN THE
WATER.
THAT WE DO ON THE COAST AS WELL
AND SO WE'VE GOT A LOT OF REALLY
GOOD STORIES TO TELL SO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU I'M YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE
WE ALWAYS HAVING TO KEEP GOING
KEEP IT STEPPING UP AND IN YOU
YOU BRING UP A GOOD POINT ABOUT
THE ORGANIC MALCOLM.
IN THIS IS KIND OF A NEW THE
NEXT PHASE.
CINEMA COUNTY IN MARIN COUNTY.
SMALLER SCALE DAIRIES BUT WHAT.
WE HAD A COMPANY --
THOSE WALLABY.
AND WHILE WE WAS BOUGHT BY A
BIGGER COMPANY WHICH I THINK WAS
BOUGHT BY A BIGGER COMPANY AND
AS YOU AS YOU GET A WITH FARTHER
AWAY FROM THE SOURCE OF THE MILK
THE BIGGEST.
THE OF THE CURRENT OWNER NOW
REALLY DOESN'T CARE THAT STORY
THEY'VE LOST THAT STORY AND SO
NOW WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
THERE'S EIGHT ORGANIC DAIRIES
THAT HAVE NO PLACE TO TAKE THEIR
MILK.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT'S
THE NEXT THING AND SO WERE
ALWAYS HAVING TO KEEP WHAT'S THE
NEXT STORY HOW DO WE TELL THAT
WHAT'S THE NEXT PRODUCT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE.
WHETHER IT'S A KEY FOR OR ITS
JOB ICE CREAM AND AND YOU KNOW
YOU COULD ALWAYS USE MORE CHEESE
BUT IT'S IT'S IT'S A IT'S ALWAYS.
AGRICULTURE IS ALWAYS GOT TO
KEEP GOING AND SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALSO IS IS TECHNOLOGY.
AND ALLOWING AND NOT MAKING THAT
THE REGULATIONS SO SO ONEROUS
THAT THEY CAN APPLY THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY AND I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE VERY INTERESTED IN THEM --
THE MILKING TECHNOLOGY WHERE YOU
HAVE AUTOMATIC MELCHIOR'S
BECAUSE THE LABOR SO SO
DIFFICULT TO GET AND SO WITH
THAT WHOLE IDEA OF OF TRYING TO
BALANCE KEEPING THESE FAMILY
FARMS --
ACTIVELY AND AND ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE AND YET MEETING THE NEEDS
A COMMUNITY.
IT'S GREAT WELL REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY
AND YOU'RE YOUR YOUR INFORMATION
I THINK WE'RE ALL INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW --
TO CREATE SUSTAINABLE WORKING
LANDSCAPES AND TO REALLY FOCUS
ON WHAT ARE THE POLICIES HERE AT
THE STATE THAT WE CAN.
CHANGE OR THAT WE CAN --
THAT WE CAN UTILIZE TO KEEP OUR
OUR AGRICULTURE GOING --
MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS --
VISIT IF WE DON'T DO IT RIGHT WE
START LOSING.
AG LAND AND RANGE LAND AND AND
ONCE IT STARTS MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION IT'S VERY HARD BECAUSE
ONCE YOU BUILD ON IT THAT TALLER
IS AND AND IN MY REGION --
THERE'S A REAL LACK OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SO PEOPLE HAVE TO
DRIVE.
IN THEIR IN THEIR VEHICLES AND
SINCE THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
NOW ARE COMING FROM THE SILICON
VALLEY INTO THEIR IN --
TO MY DISTRICT --
THE ROAD RACERS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED DURING
THAT THE PEAK TRAFFIC HOURS.
AND SO THE QUESTION BECOMES DO
WE INVEST IN PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION OR DO WE BUILD
BIGGER ROADS.
AND THE MILKMAN IT YOU START
BUILDING BIGGER ROADS ARE SECT
EXPECTATIONS --
AND AG LAND STARTS SEEMS. TWO
EXPONENTIALLY TAKEOFF AND SO HOW
WE SET.
HOW WE WORK ON OUR POLICIES AND
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WE HAVE WE
HAVE [inaudible]
PRECIOUS.
FEW RESOURCES IN A NUMBER OF
POTS AND WHERE THEY END UP GOING --
WILL DICTATE KIND OF THE KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT AND THE THE KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT AND THE EXPANSION ON
AG RANGE LAND AND SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE PREPARED FOR
SOME OF THAT REPERCUSSIONS IF WE
DON'T PLAN.
WELL AND LEAVE AND LEAVING IT UP
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT
PLANNING SO IT IT SAM.
THE MORE INFORMATION WE CAN GET
OUT ABOUT WORKING LANCE AND
ABOUT HOW --
HOW THEY OPERATE IN YOU INCLUDED
A BUNCH OF LAND SAID I DIDN'T
THINK I'M MORE FOCUSED ON REACH
LAND PARK LAND IN AN ATLANTA?
BUT THERE ARE ALL A LOT OF OTHER
RESOURCES OUT THERE THAT WE NEED
TO CONSIDER AS WELL SO I
APPRECIATE ALL THE RESEARCHER
DOING AND AND THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING.
WELL THANK YOU AND I I THINK
IT'S WHAT I FIND IS THAT THERE.
YOU CAN ALWAYS FIND A TOPIC THAT
SOMEBODY'S INTERESTED IN AND WE
HAVE A BURN MARIN COUNTY AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF INTERESTED IN
GRAZING ANIMALS AND DON'T OWN
GRAZING ANIMALS BUT THEY THEY
HAVE A PASSION FOR SEQUESTERING
CARBON.
AND IT'S JUST TAKING THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATE THE FOLKS
AND SAY WELL TO GET THE CARBON
INTO THE SOIL IN THESE RANGE
LANDS SOILS YOU HAVE TO USE A
GRAZING ANIMAL YES AND AND SO
THEN THERE THERE EXCEPT THAT
BECAUSE THEY GET THE HEALTHY
SOIL ASPECT OF IT AND SO.
IT'S REALLY JUST FIGURING OUT
HOW DO WE TELL THE AGRICULTURE
STORY [inaudible]
DIFFERENTLY.
THEN THAT WE'RE RAISING ALL THIS
FOOD IN ITS GREAT FOOD AND WE
HAVE ALL THESE YOU KNOW.
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE BUT THEN TO TAKE
THAT'S WHERE I THINK THE KEY
PIECES THE ECOSYSTEM SERVICES
AND TALKING ABOUT THE THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS THAT THEY GIVE US.
WHAT WHAT WHAT I FOUND
IMPRESSIVE IS THERE WAS AN
ARTICLE ABOUT?
A COUPLE IT BOUGHT A RANCH AND
THEY GOT RID OF ALL THE ANIMALS
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WAS --
WELL THEY DIDN'T PLAN ON RAISING
ANIMALS I GUESS NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO IS A THOUGHT IT WAS --
POLLUTING THE ENVIRONMENT AND SO --
IN THE END THERE THERE THERE
THAT RANGE LAND STARTED --
DETERIORATING SIGNIFICANTLY AND
THEY REALIZED THAT THERE WAS A
VALUE IN HAVING THOSE ANIMALS
AND THEY BROUGHT THEM BACK IN
THEIR LEARNING NEW NEW --
NEW WAYS TO BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE
THE ANIMALS IN WITH WITH THAT
KIND OF HEALTHY SOILS THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THAT WAS.
THAT WAS IN NEW INFORMATION TO
ME AND I FOUND IT FASCINATING
BECAUSE IT WE MAKE ASSUMPTIONS
ABOUT THINGS WITHOUT ANY
INFORMATION AND THEY THEY WERE
WRONG AND THEY HAD THAT.
GO BACK AND ACTUALLY RE DO THEIR
THEIR PLANTS BECAUSE THEY FOUND
THAT THE ANIMALS HAD A BENEFIT
TO THE LANDED SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK THE MORE
THAT WE CAN TELL I THINK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRACE POINT
ABOUT --
PEOPLE'S ASSUMPTIONS IS THAT
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION.
AND MY CONCERN IS IS THAT.
WHEN WE HAD A DROUGHT PEOPLE
START THINKING ABOUT WHAT SHOULD
WE NOT BE DOING ANY MORE?
AND THE NOT BE DOING ANY MORE IS
TO CAN AND CAN'T GROW.
WHERE THEY CAN AND CAN'T GROW IT
AND IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
THAT'S THE WRONG TIME TO BE
DOING THAT NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO IS WE'VE NEVER EVER BEEN A
STATE WHERE WE TELL PEOPLE THEY
CAN'T?
THEY CAN'T DO THEIR BUSINESS
ANYMORE.
THE MARKET SHOULD CONTROL THAT
NOT -- A A
SCARCITY AND A TIME WHEN THEY
WERE IN CRISIS SO ON THE MORE WE
CAN GET THIS INFORMATION UP I
THINK THE BETTER DECISIONS WILL
BE ABLE TO MAKE AND SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TAPI HERE TODAY
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
WHAT I WANNA DO IS ON AND THE
NEXT ITEM IS PUBLIC COMMENT
SOMEONE INVITE ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT TO
THE COMMITTEE TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD IF YOU COULD TELL US
YOUR NAME.
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
MADAM CHAIR I WILL BE BRIEF MY
NAME IS ADAM ROBIN I'M WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION.
NAKAL REPRESENTS A WATER
SUPPLIERS INCLUDING WATER
COMPANIES AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
LANDOWNERS AND OTHERS IN THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY WITH AN
INTEREST IN HOW OUR WATER
RESOURCES ARE MANAGED.
HOW WE THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING THAT HAD HERE
TODAY ON AND IN ADDITION TO
UNDERSCORING THE BENEFITS OF
RICE PRODUCTION THAT PAUL BUTLER
EXPLAINED IN GREAT DETAIL I WANT
TO BRIEFLY MENTION?
EFFORTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY IN THE FORM OF THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY SALMON
RECOVERY PROGRAM.
IS THE COLLABORATIVE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO TAKING
REAL STEPS TO IMPROVE --
SALMON HABITAT FOR ALL LIFE
STAGES AND ARE REMEMBERING OUR
FLOWS IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
TO PROVIDE OPTIMAL BENEFITS FOR
FISH BUT ALSO PROTECTING OUR
LOCAL LAGGED ECONOMY AND
ENSURING THAT LOCAL A
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE WATER THEY
NEED.
THESE PROJECTS INCLUDE FISH
HABITAT.
UP PROJECTS UP FISH SCREENING OF
AGRICULTURAL WATER DIVERSIONS
AND AGAIN COMPREHENSIVE EFFORTS
TO RE MANAGER FLOWS IN SUCH A
MANNER THAT WE'RE PROTECTING OUR
ECONOMY PROVIDE ENSURING WE HAVE
WATER FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
BUT ALSO ENSURING WITH HELP YOU
HEALTHY FISH POPULATIONS WE
THINK THAT THAT TYPE OF
COLLABORATIVE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
STATE RIGHT NEEDS RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU KNOW THERE MANY
DISCUSSIONS UNDER WAY ABOUT HOW
WE MANAGE OUR RIVERS AND A WATER
SYSTEM AS A STATE A WE THINK
THAT LOOKING BEYOND FLOW TO
THESE OTHER TYPES OF PROJECTS.
ON AS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF
LAW.
IS REALLY KEY SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY AND AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT WILL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE THAT WAS
EXACTLY THE THOUGHT I HAD ABOUT
THAT PROJECT THEIR RIGHTS
PROJECT BECAUSE IF THEY'RE IF
THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL THEN THERE
MAY BE.
OTHER STRATEGIES FOR OUR A
RESURGENCE OF THE SALMON
POPULATION THAT WE HAVEN'T EVEN
CONSIDERED IN THAT THE FLOWS ARE
NOT THE ONLY ANSWER I GUESS IS
MY WATER SUPPLIERS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE ON THE LEADING EDGE OF
IMPLEMENTING THESE PROGRAMS.
PROJECTS MANY MORE PLANNED AN
EVEN MORE POSSIBLE AND I THINK
THE EXCITING POTENTIAL FOR FLOOD
PLAIN --
RECONNECTING FLOOD PLAINS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY CLAIBORNE WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE CHAIR WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO SET FOR PUBLIC HONOR.
AS LONG AS YOU DON'T GET TOO
COMFORTABLE.
I'LL TRY TO BE AS BRIEF AS I CAN --
SO I WANT TO START BY SAYING
WELL FIRST OF ALL MY NAME'S MIKE
CLAIBORNE ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND I REPRESENT --
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND EAST
COACHELLA VALLEY.
I DON'T WANNA START MY COMMENT
BY SAYING THAT WE SUPPORT AG
LAND CONVERSION AND SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE.
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED TODAY SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY --
AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
CONSERVATION OF AG LAND AS
OPPOSED AG LAND CONVERSION TO
URBAN LAND USES DISCOURAGES
URBAN SPRAWL --
THAT INCREASES GHG EMISSIONS
VEHICLES MILES TRAVELED AND
LOCAL AIR QUALITY IMPACTS --
WE WORKED ON REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS THROUGHOUT
THE FOR THE LAST HOUR WHAT FIVE
DEAD. SEVEN YEARS THAT
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AS IT EXISTED.
AND WE SEE THIS AS A REAL --
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE
BETWEEN AGRICULTURE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO MAKE
SURE NOT CONVERTING --
ATLANTA NECESSARILY AND INSTEAD
ENCOURAGING --
URBAN DEVELOPMENT THAT'S DANCE
AND CENTERED AROUND.
TOWN CENTERS AND ALSO FOCUSED ON
TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION RATHER THAN ROAD
EXPANSION --
SO IF WE SEE THAT AS A ROOM FOR
COLLABORATION --
WE ALSO WANTED TO THINK --
MANY OF WITH WHOM WERE HERE
EARLIER TODAY --
BUT THOSE WHO AND WITHIN
AGRICULTURE THAT SUPPORTED THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER ACT --
WHICH WE SEE AS ESSENTIAL --
TO SOLVING THE DRINKING WATER
CRISIS THAT'S AFFECTING THE
STATE.
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
ON DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES --
WITH THAT SAID I THINK THERE'S A
FEW THINGS THAT ARE MISSING FROM
TODAY'S HEARING AND WE ASK FOR
I'M A FOLLOW HEARING --
WE'D LIKE TO ENGAGE IN A
DISCUSSION OF DEFERRED
IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN BE MADE
WITHIN AGRICULTURE --
INCLUDING --
THE ISSUE AREAS OF PESTICIDES
DUST WATER QUALITY DEGRADATION
AIR QUALITY DEGRADATION --
AND DE TO THE EXTENT THOSE
ISSUES ARE RELATED TO
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES --
TO THAT AND THERE ARE SEVERAL
POINTS THAT --
WE'D LIKE FOR THE DISCUSSION
AROUND --
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
AGRICULTURE ACCOUNTS FOR THE
MAJORITY OF METHANE EMISSIONS IN
THE STATE.
AND THE ED DAIRY INDUSTRY
ACCOUNT ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT 75%
OF THOSE EMISSIONS.
WERE CONCERNED WITH THE STATE'S
GROWING RELIANCE ON VERY TIGHT
JESTERS TO ADDRESS THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE --
THE ESPECIALLY TO THE EXTENT
THAT RELY ON PUBLIC SUBSIDIES --
WE SEE THAT THIS IS A FAIRLY ON
PROVEN METHOD --
TO RESPONSE TO METHANE EMISSIONS
FROM THE DAIRY INDUSTRY --
AND THEY DID NOT ADDRESS RELATED
AIR QUALITY AND WATER QUALITY
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE WITH
RESPECT --
TO THE INDUSTRY.
IN FACT PUBLIC SUBSIDIES COULD
EXASPERATED AND FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS FROM
DAIRIES BY INCENTIVIZING
INCREASED HER EXCISE.
AND POTENTIALLY EXPANDING AN
INDUSTRY THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE CURRENTLY OF AIR QUALITY
AND WATER QUALITY POLLUTION IN
THE STATE --
WITH RESPECT TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY THE CLAIM THAT BY A
METHANE DISCOURAGES THE USE OF
DIESEL AND TRANSPORTATION.
ARE WE KNOW THAT --
MOST AT THAT PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED ON GENERATION OF BIO
METHANE.
AND AT ADDING THAT BY MATH AND
AND THINGS [inaudible]
PIPELINES SO IT'S NOT REALLY
FOCUSED ON TRANSPORTATION
RELATED IMPACTS ARE AS OF YET --
SO WE THINK THAT THOSE CLAIMS
SHOULD BE REVIEWED CRITICALLY --
AND THAT THERE ARE ALSO
SIGNIFICANT UNKNOWNS REGARDING
IMPACTS OF TERRY DI JESTERS
WHICH WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THIS.
COMMITTEE AND I AND OTHERS IN
THE INDUSTRY TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND --
HOW TO MITIGATE ANYTHING RELATED
TO THEIR DIGESTERS?
WITH RESPECT IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURE WE'D KNOW THAT AND
THE TWENTY TWELVE STUDY PREPARED
BY UC DAVIS WHICH WERE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH LIKELY --
ONE THIRD OF DOMESTIC WELLS IN
THE TULARE LAKE BASIN IN THE
SALINAS VALLEY EXCEEDED THE
NITRATE MCO FOR DRINKING WATER.
AND THAT SAME SET A STUDY
CONCLUDED THAT 96% OF HUMAN
GENERATED NITRATE IS SOURCED
IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE AND
DAIRIES.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT RIGHT
CURRENT REGULATION HASN'T
SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESSED.
AND WE SEE.
ROOM FOR BETTER REGULATION AND
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS --
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S THE NITROUS
OXIDE STUDY THAT WAS --
COMPLETED THIS YEAR SHOWING
AGRICULTURE CONTRIBUTES BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND 40% OF TOTAL
KNOCKS EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY ADDRESSED --
AT LEAST NOT THE POINT IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED --
AND JUST TO CLOSE AGRICULTURE
AND STATE POLICYMAKERS CAN AND
MUST DO MORE TO PROTECT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR FROM AIR
QUALITY AND WATER QUALITY
POLLUTION.
WE CALL FOR LEGISLATION AND
REGULATORY IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
COMING YEARS TO ADDRESS THESE
IMPACTS CEMENTED MANDATE IMPROVE
PRACTICES.
I WORK WITH COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY SUFFERING FOR MANY OF
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT I
DISCUSSED TODAY AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS WATER QUALITY THAT --
IS NOT FIT TO DRINK --
AS I JUST THINK THAT WE CAN ALL
WORKED VERY.
HARD TOGETHER TO BETTER
MITIGATING AVOID NEGATIVE
IMPACTS IN THE FUTURE.
ESPECIALLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WITH IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN IS COACHELLA VALLEY'S
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
DISCUSS ANY OF THESE POINTS
FURTHER BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING THANKS THANK
YOUTHANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS HERE
TODAY AND THE NAY TREATS ISSUES.
HE IT'S HISTORIES BEEN YEARS IN
THE MAKING SO THAT SAID THAT'S A
LEGACY ISSUE THAT THAT WE'VE GOT
TO WORK WITH WE HAVE TO WORK ON
AND NO QUESTION IT'S SERIOUS
HEALTH ISSUE --
FOR DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS --
AND AND DUMB AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE SO I REALLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH UNFORTUNATELY THIS
COMMITTEE HAS NO JURISDICTION
OVER PESTICIDES.
GO FIGURE --
BUT UP BUT IT'S IT'S OUT ORTON
OR NORM OUR WATER QUALITY
BELIEVE IT OR NOT BUT NAM THOSE
ARE SERIOUS ISSUES IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND I'M I'M WITH YOU
HAD A PERCENT THERE ARE THINGS
WE NEED TO DO THAT --
MILLION AMELIORATED MEDICAID --
THOSE AND HOPEFULLY SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
TAKE A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION
THERE AND ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK
THERE'S ROOM TO WORK TOGETHER ON
CONVERSION ARE I MEAN.
PREVENTING CONVERSION OF ACT YES
YES I AGREE WITH THE THANK YOU
SO MUCH WITH THAT DIE IF THERE
ARE NO OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS.
UP WANTED THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE UP REALLY AS
I SAID IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING THE PURPOSE REALLY WAS
TO TO START HAVING THIS DIALOGUE
ABOUT -- THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE --
TO USE AND AT UTILIZE ALL OF OUR
RESOURCES IN THE STATE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS --
AND TO SEQUESTER AS MUCH AS WE
CAN AND SO THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN IN IN THAT DIRECTION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IT'S BEEN VERY.
VERY VERY HELPFUL APPRECIATED.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR COMMITTEE
ON AGRICULTURE FOR TODAY